the largest oil pipeline
has been temporarily shut down a state
of emergency was declared in 17
different states in washington dc and
there are fears that there could
this could end up causing gas shortages
and maybe even
a spike in gas prices which are already
up as it is now there's talk of
inflation there is fear that the bill
is coming due all that money that was
being printed
all of these people who are getting 16
an hour in unemployment all of these
signs
popping up across all these different
fast food restaurants where they say we
quit we won't work here anymore
and there are fears that the economy
isn't going to be recovering like many
people think
this past job jobs report was actually
surprisingly bad
i guess they said it was the biggest
miss since 1993 but don't take my advice
for it
because i brought in the experts to
actually help us break down what's going
on and we have
uh the legendary max and stacy max
kaiser and stacy herbert
now let me just say before i want to ask
you guys
excellent i'm on the on the tim pool
cast
you know that's the kind of feeling i
like to get let me let me just say one
thing real quick
if you guys listened to max and stacy
when they start when they were first
shouting out bitcoin yeah and you
invested when they told you to no joke
you would be a billionaire
that's right we've made many
billionaires all over the world 100
millionaires we've
you know our show goes out globally 50
countries millions of folks we've
we estimate we've created a half a
million millionaires around the world
wow and um you know started buying it at
the dollar
and uh we were the only ones covering it
in the world for several years
and um you know we we just wherever we
go we're treated
like saints basically a lot of people
are photos of max and stacy on their
wall with little
candles burning and incense and there's
uh
stacy and andreas antonopoulos those are
the two holy saints of
of the bitcoin universe wherever you go
around the world i
will say that there are probably more
millionaires than billionaires tim
because
you can't forget that between 2011 and
now
it was very easy to spend or lose or
have your
coins hacked so very few will have kept
all those coins that they uh got back in
you know when it was a dollar
as you where we were pointing out before
the show is like
when it hits a hundred dollars you're
like whoa like i have so much money
but not just uh i think we'll talk a lot
about bitcoin because of
you know what's happening with the
economy but i mean you both have talked
about the economy in general
more than you know you're just
explaining to us how the fed works the
interest rates
so it's gonna be really interesting
people are worried about inflation and i
guess the the fed has on a 180 like no
no no there's no inflation we were
we're kidding it's not happening because
people are worried so
we're gonna get into all that we also
got ian shillings what's up everybody
ian crosslandian crossland.net
did you guys see like when obama
basically bailed out fannie mae and
freddie mac is that when the writing
went on the wall and you were like
oh it goes back to 87 crash of 1987.
and i was working on wall street at the
time and that was the beginning really
of when the
federal government kind of took over
markets because you had the crash of 87
and the next day the markets were set to
open another
500 points down or 22 23 down as the
biggest percent move down in the history
of the stock market
and you had alan greenspan ronald reagan
and
um the other fellow over there
um ruben rubin they created the
the working group on finance which
became known as the plunge protection
team
and they started buying stocks in the
open market and the federal government
and so this is when you had the the
beginning of the end of
free market capitals in america was
really then in 1987.
so subsequently throughout the the
decades since then the government's
become more
intrusive into the workings of the
uh market so you you ended up having
under greenspan what became known as the
greenspan
put which became the bernanke put which
became the janet yellen put which is now
the j
powell put and what that refers to is
every time the markets go down
the feds come in and they buy markets so
you you don't have any risk and
uh they eliminate the risk particularly
in the in the large fund and hedge fund
universe they know that they are playing
a rig
game where the risk is minimal to zero
they're borrowing money at zero uh
they're speculating
uh without any restrictions or laws
being enforced against them whatsoever
and whenever they make a mistake they
get bailed out so it's heads they win
tails we lose
so buy bitcoin no no no not financial
advice but let's uh we'll get into all
this stuff we also got lydia pushing the
buttons i am in the corner i have to
admit this is my first exposure to max
and stacy and i am
so excited for tonight i've known you
guys for a really long time like
right back to occupy wall street yeah
yeah we were hanging out in paris that
was so much fun
and you're still the same age i know i i
don't age what is going on
magic jim pool is the the fountain of
youth
part asian no that's that's right that's
incredible all right
uh before we get started ladies and
gentlemen go over to timcast.com
there's a big beautiful blue button says
members only and you can sign up
for our members only uh four members
only at teamguys.com help support our
work in the event we get banned
or purged or whatever but also we do
have exclusive members only segments
you can actually sign up now with stripe
because a lot of people are requesting
something other than paypal which is
available
then you click the members area and you
can see our awesome segments that are
only available to members
last week i talked about how venezuela
hacked my friends facebook trying to spy
on me and get me to reveal my location
while i was reporting from venezuela
and i showed the phone messages from the
venezuelan
agents or whoever they were if you want
to see that you got to be a member but
don't forget to like
share subscribe subscribe to this
channel share this video
and if you're listening on itunes
spotify or wherever else leave us a good
review give us five stars
let's talk about this first story
because this is this is major breaking
news
we have this from axios emergency
declaration issued in 17
states in dc over fuel pipeline cyber
attack
so the department of transportation's
federal motor carrier safety
administration administration issued
a regional emergency declaration for 17
states and washington dc
to keep fuel supply lines open colonial
pipeline carries 45 percent of fuel
supplies in the eastern u.s
some 5500 miles of pipeline have has
been shut down
in response to the attack so if you're
not familiar with the store this is a
ransomware attack basically hit one of
the systems at colonial i don't know if
it actually hit the industrial control
systems
but their computers which basically
means
their their their administrative
computers this co these hackers
have said unless you give us money we're
going to encrypt your machines you'll
never be able to use them
they shut down in responses it's typical
of what happens to companies when they
do get hit by this but this is a
major attack on our critical
infrastructure now the funny thing about
this i think
is that uh the hackers have apologized
my bad yeah we won't take the money
it was it was they release it error of
judgment on our part
start shipping that oil again reopen the
east coast sorry
well so so uh the people who made the
ransomware i guess
yeah said that we'll have to vet our
clients and
and implement moderation policies
definitely that's a good recommendation
there's some standards in these hacking
communities hacking communities have got
to get some standards how do they have
more standards
than like the fed well you know it's
like when i was living in harlem they
used to say
uptown uh there are no cops because
uh you know you are the law the law you
are you have to be honest because
there's no cops
right so in the hawk in the hacker
community there's no cop so you have to
be honest
there has to be standards so so i guess
basically these this this
hacker group what are they called
they're called dark side fbi names dark
side as the colonial pipeline cyber
attacker
i guess they sold the ransomware to
someone yeah who then used it
and ended up getting a pipeline you know
shut down
yeah if you if you're one of these
hackers you know
you don't want the pipeline shut down
you you want to use your money for stuff
so what's the point of getting the money
if like there's no oil what are you
gonna do go buy a farm i guess
well it brings up you know a couple of
points the infrastructure in in the
united states is weak and getting weaker
and it's a huge problem and there's very
little funds to take care of it
and also you have uh the the ransomware
and the inability to deal with that is
kind of a secondary problem but
primarily the roads bridges tunnels
infrastructure pipelines oil pipelines
these things have gone neglected for
decades
and now they're starting to fall apart
and the um federal budget this doesn't
have any budget to
to repair these things that gov the
country is already broke
so and their and their solution to him
is always the same print money
this is not real money
you want to spray real money you can
spend real money well you told me i
shouldn't rip up real money don't rip up
you know
don't really i was ready to shred
another 20 000 bucks right here on the
tim cass you're like no no
don't do it i'm like listen i'm max
kaiser i rip up money
that's what i do and tim's like no no
don't do it don't do it
so i gotta use the fake money i gotta
use the fake money but this is all they
can do they say oh the bridge broke
let's print money oh the pipeline's
broke let's print money
oh uh we need more roads and bridges
let's print money oh there's not enough
minimum wage jobs let's print more money
that's all they know how to do
they don't know how to do anything else
that's the entire policy of every
freaking politician in
america that's it how much did they
print last year
like uh 58 trillion dollars 50.
no no no no no no they increased the
money supply by 25
so um it was just like three trillion or
something it goes it goes from yelling
to stacy's calm
yeah yeah yeah they're just adding more
zeros there's no cost too it's like
it's like remember when zimbabwe wasn't
zimbabwe where they had like the billion
dollar bills
trillions of trillion dollars yeah i
like also that
you know over the past since 2008 they
keep on pretending
like that they're all meeting together
all these academics and economists and
they're
gonna come up with a new plan and it's
all the same it's the same exact money
printing and they protect they call it a
new thing
and they're like now we're gonna try
this let's let's go back to the gas
pipeline real quick
you mentioned uh go to the wayback
machine the wayback machine
infrastructure infrastructure's
crumbling think about yeah
think about computers 20 years ago or
whatever when they built the industrial
control systems for these pipelines
yeah and that's that's that's the level
of technology many hackers need to
overcome
and it's like 80s computer technology
yeah they
they use uh what's that operating uh
system from the 80s and the 70s unix
oh no cobalt what they use
our entire banking infrastructure is on
cobalt
and there's only like three guys who
know how to program it wow and those
guys are
you know uh paid a lot of money but yeah
hold on security through obscurity
yes yes yes they actually say that yeah
i know yeah
it's a common phrase so what happens is
it's so archaic
it may actually be easy to hack but
you're going to get some like
18 year old hacker and russia being like
i have no idea what this
is what is this language but there are
only like a handful of guys who
still know how to use it speaking of uh
like people being uh
like please work for us please please
like they're in retirement they're in
their 70s and they're like we just want
to be retired
yeah but our whole banking
infrastructure's about to collapse come
fix it
it's crazy to me that you had people
they built up this system and then
basically shrugged and walked away from
it
and it's falling apart yeah yeah well
they're cheap
it's like you know the
but as max will also point out you know
the whole derivatives that
the complexity and the in the financial
system now is just so huge that
by the time like more advanced stuff
came around they
they just didn't know how to unwind any
of it like it's all
trapped in this old system yeah they
don't have to get it so
so wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you know yeah i
talk a bit about this
watching all the different stuff that's
been happening over the past few years
you know
police departments cops are quitting
like crazy the riots are getting more
emboldened
uh you know and i say things like it
feels like things are collapsing they're
falling apart
there's a rot inside the core but you
guys have been talking about that for
for
way longer than i've been around so so
you've been watching this spread i mean
especially from financial markets
particularly
yeah because the markets are rotten and
the and the money that we use
is rotten the us dollar is rotten yeah
money is rotten
goes back to the 1971 when nixon took us
off
out of the gold standard essentially and
the world started on a very bold
experiment every country in the world
had fiat money that is this hey it's not
backed by gold or anything
and so it became referential to other
fiat money so the dollar is valued
against the euro which is backed by
nothing back
by the yen backed by the chinese yuan
it's all it's a circle jerk
that goes around and round and round i
think it's backed by
a bunch of people with guns telling you
it's worth something that's what paul
krugman says at the new york times he
says that the reason the dollar has
value is it's backed by men with guns
and um that's true it is that's why you
say fiat money is violence it promotes
violence it is violence and it is
uh promotes war the petro dollar
certainly is part of the
u.s dollar matrix and that is all about
war
and uh the cartel and everything that
goes on in the middle east and it's all
dollar related but if they can just
print out money as easily as i can pull
this trigger and
fire off some why can't they just fix
our infrastructure with it
because they give it to banks and the
banks buy chateaus and property on park
avenue
and jamie dimon is a billionaire so
occupy wall street yeah
yeah they have a problem and that is
that the us dollar has reserve currency
they can't they have to send it overseas
you can't you can't control the world
you can't have dollar hegemony you can't
have american hegemony
without sending those dollars overseas
so they don't spend it here
because that would cause inflation and
they don't want inflation so they send
it to china they send it to europe they
send it to the middle east
and that is supposed to sustain this
hegemonic system
if they stop sending it overseas if they
were to start
building factories and employing people
across
michigan and iowa and idaho and places
like that
then uh the the the dollar would no
longer be the result right right the
trade deficit so
dig into it i mean go into the dig it
dig it
dig into it some more i mean this is
really fascinating stuff this is the the
metal of it
this is the triffen dilemma that's
called the tripping dilemma
what's going on well the chiffon dilemma
is something that was warned about
when we did bretton woods back in 1944
and trifan had warned that uh the
problem with having a reserve currency
is that the that um your geo
the geopolitics versus your domestic
economics
they they get into conflict and that's
the point we're at now
we hit it first in 1971 um because
as the currents as a reserve currency
country
we had to send all our dollars overseas
right
and that was backed by gold so what
you're doing is you're sending your gold
overseas
and when uh france sent their warship
into the harbor of new york to come
collect their gold
they got their gold england asked for
their gold they didn't get their gold we
shut the
gold window but since 1971 what's the
next step of the trip and dilemma you
send your manufacturing you hollow out
your manufacturing base and that's what
we've done
we're at that end point that's why
you're seeing this disintegration
you know it's just the entropy of the
system it's the entropy of the american
empire of the dollar system
things things disintegrate faster and
faster yeah yeah
you guys know about the fourth turning
yeah yeah yeah we had uh um um
who was it was it ben norton uh ben
stewart ben stewart who's ben norton i
don't know
cool name though yeah ben norton is that
left wing guy who works with max
oh that's right that's right that's
right well shout out ben wait no we had
ben stewart he was talking about
the uh the book and a lot of the stuff
that he was studying
and yeah i guess the the the theory
whether it's true and a lot of people
say it's bunk it's just nonsense but uh
no it's good
2020 we've covered it uh yeah well they
wrote about it in the 1980s and they
said it would be 2025 would be the year
to look for
they said back then yeah so earlier uh i
showed you guys um
we're going to we're going to release
the secret live on the air that there is
a
secret room in this in this building
that no one knows about and in it was uh
food and beans and bullets and yeah so
good idea huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was uh it's good
i want one i want to live there
can we can you rent it that could be
like an airbnb
well so we had a tornado warning
recently like legit and like the the
male lady came up and she's like get
inside now they just called it in it's
like
there's a funnel cloud it's coming right
this way yeah and so we go it's
underground it's like this underground
thing
no wind you know no windows it's
literally edible gummy bears
that's all that's all that's in there
because the idea is if you're going to
die
you want to just feel good on the way
yeah no no it's it's it's literally a
storage room um we have like
right you know i don't know ian bought
like 20 gallons of vinegar for some
reason i'm not done yet
but i don't want to get into that
you know uh in in the context of uh war
and fourth turning are you guys familiar
with thucydides trap yes
we talk about we have an episode of our
show called
uh when uh fourth turning meets who sit
at easter
oh wow yeah that's what's happening yeah
yeah it's not happened before has it no
yeah well the oh maybe the two of them
happening together probably it's
happened eighteen times the thucydides
right right 16 have ended violently for
those that aren't familiar it's
basically
um and correct me if i'm wrong that when
that when a a rising economic power
meets
is about to overtake the dominant power
war breaks out yes and that happened in
the past few years
and you notice all the propaganda
against china sure china
is a different system than our own and
there are many problems with it
obviously but we really started becoming
very hostile to them
once they overtook us and 5g artificial
intelligence all the high-tech stuff
which remember joe biden had mentioned
back in
2000 when he was you know encouraging uh
congress to vote to uh elevate them to
the wto on favored nation status he was
like
uh china's gonna eat our lunch come on
man
it's not going to happen no way that's
so but but it seems like
you know biden and many billionaires and
big corporations are totally deferential
to china
if not absolutely supporting china yeah
they don't care they'll go where the
money is right exactly hollywood edits
they know
the favor chinese government and things
like that i think and the top gun in
china
uh tom cruise is actually chinese in the
chat in that in the release
really no well but i wouldn't be
surprised if they said he was
well they did change a lot of
iconography because you know they would
change
like the storyline but they got rid of
the the the tibet campaign or whatever
from taiwan
taiwan that's what it was yeah taiwan
right yeah now i wouldn't be surprised i
did something like that
in in that one movie camera what it was
they added the lines over the south
china sea
yeah animated movie yeah so it's like a
little girl walks past a world map and
it's china and the lines for the south
china sea are
like well that's that's the through
city's trap so the china drives the
global economy and they're going to
drive the cultural agenda as well so
the thing that really the thing that
changed the thing that put us
on the path towards a violent conflict
with 2014 the belt and road initiative
so what always happens is as i was
mentioning
when you have the world's reserve
currency you have to send your dollars
overseas otherwise there's
because they can't print dollars so you
have to get it to circulate so
uh we were sending first we were sending
saudi arabia the europe they and they
kept
recycling it back into treasuries well
that's what china did until 2014.
then they started taking their dollars
and uh
lending it to africa lending it across
asia
to other nations and building
infrastructure and ports and stuff like
that
and that's the u.s u.s citizens yeah and
uh america was like wait
this is cheating it's not cheating
really but it's uh we're gonna say it's
cheating
when we loan money to china are we
borrowing it from the federal reserve
and then we owe the interest to the
federal reserve and then loan it out or
does the money get loaned to the chinese
and they owe the interest to the federal
reserve
uh well we basically we owe them we have
a trade deficit with them
so you have to run massive trade
deficits right when
when you have the reserve currency so
that's the lie that nobody will tell the
american people
you know trump came close to it when he
was like make america great again
but the point is you have to tell people
like we either have the reserve currency
or we have a domestic economy which do
you want
and when you say we run a deficit what
is that exactly what does that mean so
uh
china uh sends us say half a bill
say for ease say a trillion dollars
worth of goods
and we only send them 200 billion worth
of goods so they they send us 800
billion more we
we send them 800 billion more than we uh
than we sell to them they're getting
more from us
than we're getting back is that what it
is yeah they they're selling us their
goods
yeah you know and we're we sell them
less and less
let's talk about the the ramifications
of you know mass money printing and all
this stuff i have the story from axios
the wild ride of pandemic consumer
prices
i find it interesting that they just
they say it's the pandemic right
as opposed to what's been going on in
this country for some time when you
uh so we've looked at the m1 money stock
quite a bit and some sometimes m2 i'm
not
i'm not you guys know better than i do
but you can see around 2008
there's a major uptick in you know the
money stock and then at the pandemic
massive spike so i think this this kind
of stuff's been happening for a long
time
but they show us laundry detergent i'm
sorry laundry equipment is up 29
car and truck rentals 24 major
appliances 19
propane kerosene firewood 15 pork chops
11.
used cars and trucks are up 10 then
there's weird stuff like
women's dresses are down 14 public
transportation is down 15.
men's suits are down telephone hardware
is actually down 20 which is interesting
and airline fares have dropped
dramatically
i think that's for obvious reasons but
uh just to point out lumber prices have
skyrocketed yeah
steel has skyrocketed there's a shortage
of a lot of computer equipment so we've
been trying to
we've been waiting now for over a month
to get a new computer for for the studio
right and we keep getting told from
everybody hard to come by can't get it
sorry
it's been particularly difficult prices
are going way up yeah they are yeah well
you mentioned computer components and
the price they're saying is going down
but that's actually if you dig into it a
lot of times it's a lie for example if
the phone
they'll say it's twice as fast as the
phone that you bought two years ago
they'll say that means that the price
has dropped by fifty percent even though
you still paid the amount the same
amount
right thousand dollars they say actually
it's it's fifty percent cheaper because
it's twice as fast
and that's what they cook into their
books and when they govern the bureau of
labor statistics reports the cpi numbers
the numbers are cooked they're rigged
they to show an outcome that they have
pre-configured they want to show 1.6
or whatever the number is and they do
whatever they can to hedonically adjust
these numbers to get to that number
because
they have an incentive to keep the
reported inflation as low as possible
all right so i'm i'm i'm sure that
you're both bitcoin trillionaires
yeah at this point uh but but for the
first we're in it for the technology
but for the for the regular people right
regular people right
now who have been working 40 hours a
week they've been they've been getting
paid they're watching people get paid 60
bucks an unemployment yeah
the people that are seeing all the stuff
the price is increasing what do they
need to know and what what what do you
think people should look out for
well the inflation's here it's a secular
move in inflation it's not going to be
temporary
it's going to be now structurally baked
into the economy and prices are going to
start to go up
on a regular basis and the re the reason
why i wasn't as visible
as it has been with all the money
printing that has gone on is that
essentially jobs were shipped over to
china
and that kept the numbers low for a long
time because
there was no wage pressure but now since
the middle class in china has equaled
more or less middle class in america you
don't really have that the sink
of cheap labor anymore right so now
prices are going to start
moving up in reflection of their actual
money supply numbers for real
and that's what people are seeing so one
key statistic and this is true
is that once the price the um
budget of the average family once uh
they allocate 40
to food that's when you usually see an
insurrection so we saw it in egypt
when price got to 40 there was a
revolution
we saw it in france the french
revolution the food cost got to around
40 percent
in the u.s uh for a vast majority of
folks we're now bumping into that
we're getting now approaching that 40
number so that would indicate
historically that you're getting
close to a flash point where an
insurrection would become um
historically the norm
wow you're also like that's scary
all those things you're talking not
really did you guys buy like a mountain
bunker in new zealand or something
it's normal i mean you know things
happen and uh yes
cycles happen and the thucydides trap as
you mentioned that's going to lead to
deglobalization you're already seeing
the deglobalization that causes prices
to rise
you have the fourth turning uh this
young generation the generation z
aren't going to do you think they're
really going to um
give 80 of their wages over to the
retired boomers no they're not going to
right no why i wouldn't they have the
numbers as well so
they're going to just you know tell them
to stick it
then um the in terms of the uh inflation
numbers
yeah like we're at the end of that cycle
as well we're at the end of the dollar
the triffin dilemma has reached the end
game and
you see that with the extraordinary
amount of money i mean max and i have
been reporting on
the global financial crisis since 2008
2009
and the stuff they're doing now is just
beyond any of that
right it's like if you look at the
charts of of the money printing and the
interventions in the economy
now versus 2008 um
it's like it's beyond anything it's so
ridiculous
and yet you know we're still in the
crack of boom side of it like things are
like
stock markets are all-time highs house
prices at all-time highs
like incomes are up 20 over 20 percent
in the last year for the ordinary
american
incomes are up 20 most of it from the uh
government transfers so you know these
are crack up boom times and they're
printing more and more
like you're supposed to do the money
printing that the theory is
under keynes is you're not supposed to
do that during the crack up boom times
you're supposed to wait for the crash
but they're not even waiting for the
crash anymore are they again getting
back to this green span put or the
imaginations of the plunge protection
team or the government in terms of
markets is that they would not allow for
a normal business cycle
to take place yes where you have a
downturn
and then you get rid of for example the
banks in 2008 were caught
committing massive fraud and so in a
normal capitalist economy a business
cycle those banks would have had to go
bankrupt
and we would have had new banks and new
jobs and but instead they bailed out the
creditors they bailed out the banks
again historically you never see that
usually in a
crisis like that the debtors get bailed
out the people who are at the
mortgages and the debit credit cards
would get bailed out not the not the
banks who made the fraudulent loans
right they got bailed out and what they
did with that what was called 16
trillion dollars of bailout money when
it's all said and done
is they simply were allowed to expand
their credit card
expand their credit facilities and do
the exact same things that caused the
crisis in 2008
but to do it 10 times to 20 times bigger
and 20 times worse and we've been saying
now for 10 years that you know
what's going to happen in 10 to 12 years
is the is going to be the 2008 crisis
part two
and that's exactly what we're in now
it's just the same crisis from 2008.
the the global economy died in 2008 but
now it's getting
buried now it's like it's like a lich is
that how you say it yeah
that's one way to say it you know it's
like an undead like just
reanimated courses well how many zombie
companies are there in the united states
something like 30 percent of the s p 500
are companies that
can't really afford to pay interest on
the debt that they carry on their books
from their earnings they're technically
zombies they're dead companies they're
the walking dead and that's like a third
of all the s p 500 and they're just kept
alive by free money printing it's just
like money money money money
what's amazon just announced today that
they're going to float
billions of dollars of the bonds guess
what to do what
to buy back their own stock is what's
going to happen so here again
it's zero percent money uh for some
which is incredibly
um you know dangerous for example when
amazon bought whole foods it was
accretive from day one
they cost them nothing they bought it
for nothing when um
tiffany was bought by lvmh in europe
they bought tiffany
how much did they pay to buy tiffany a
multi-billion dollar company they paid
exactly nothing
because the european central bank lent
them
all the money they needed the central
bank to buy tiffany's with
no interest they gave them tiffany's as
a gift they're already the biggest
luxury company in the world
it just kind of sounds like fascism it's
a corporatism
but also like it's important to point
out that in the past year
we've done fiscal stimulus so since 2008
it's been
just federal reserve stimulus and that's
credit to the banking system
so it's not cash this is cash this is
what they've been printing the
trillions of dollars that the u.s
government is printing
that is high velocity real money that is
what causes
the big inflation yeah yeah right so so
uh
is this why you guys were saying by
bitcoin like back in the day we were
gold bugs into in 2011 and then we were
introduced to bitcoin
and we immediately realized that this
was digital hard money i have a
background
in virtual currencies going back to the
mid 90s i created the hollywood stock
exchange which
created i invented a digital currency in
1996. i have a patent on that digital
currency
so i immediately recognized that this
could do what we were trying to get that
to do back in the mid 90s
and um so we went from gold over to
bitcoin
and it's kind of like when dylan went
electric
so we i i'm gonna i'm we're gonna have
to come back to this conversation so put
a pin in because we got we got breaking
news lydia just pulled this up
this is from uh bloomb bloomberg law is
this this is from bloomberg law
yeah gas stations running dry as hacked
pipeline tries to restart
so yeah we we were worried actually on
the drive up here because i was i was
like
guys yeah we've got this a little bunker
you know put some cottons and they've
got some hammocks
and there's beans that's right and we
got a lot of mres just because they're
fun
yeah but do you have mre gasoline
no i do have an electric car
okay and my van is got uh is is solar
powered
so in the apocalypse i can actually plug
my electric car
into the uh uh the the solar power from
the van yeah
and in probably about two or three weeks
you'll be able to drive the electric
well look this is a function of too much
debt so um
the infrastructure is breaking down and
you before the
up until a few years ago you had this
just-in-time economy where things were
logistically all connected you had
globalization and you had this incentive
to keep
all these systems going at the absolute
rock bottom cheapest price and to not
pay anybody anything
in terms of a decent wage but once the
thucydides trap kicks in once the u.s
dollar loses its status as world reserve
currency
then it what it reveals all of the
shortcomings in the system and it
reveals all the fragility in the system
and there's suddenly no way to
repair these uh infrastructure projects
because the money's being
sent out directly from the treasury to
appease the rabble rousers from
staging an insurrection i mean this is
what they do in countries where they pop
with the population's about to insurrect
as they try to throw money at them to
appease them and that works for a short
period of time and then it doesn't work
so how much time do you got left well
every every time you read a story like
that like oh you know we ran out of
microchips so the cards that aren't
being delivered oh
gas lines and not being restarted can't
get gas oh
the price of food is not 40 of my weekly
budget right you add all those data
points up
and every day you get new data points so
it's it's tough to say exactly when the
pot boils but uh it's
it's happening but i say get ready for
good times because you know this
stuff has to end for the next generation
to have their way right right the night
is always darkest before the dawn
yeah yeah it's good for millennials and
you know that great century
uh yeah and the generation z who are
like 25 years old now
uh the oldest ones and that in terms of
those microchips you know
you have been talking about cycles and
and the business cycle
that used to exist when max and i were
you know your age
we had the business cycle and the thing
about the semi
conductor chips is they you know they
never
they never planned nobody expected the
money printing
like the fiscal stimulus right so what
happened is naturally these business
executives saw a pandemic saw
global lockdown and they cancelled their
orders they said we don't need
we're not going to need those cars
because we're on lockdown right
nope they didn't expect the thousands
and thousands of dollars to be thrown at
everybody and everybody to go on a
buying spree so
there were backlogs like everybody all
these auto companies had cancelled their
orders expecting that things would
be slowing down and across the board
computers phones all that stuff every
everything that you use as a microchip
they were not expecting
so much money it sounds like there's two
there's two things i'm kind of hearing
from what you guys are saying the first
is that there are people who decided the
ship's sinking extract as much as you
can before it goes down and yeah bail
yourself out
but the other thing is you know i
mentioned the fascism thing because when
you say like the central banks are
giving this money to like amazon to buy
whole foods or whatever it sounds like
the government is
surreptitiously empowering massive
corporate monopolies to seize power
totally it's not even the government
it's a private corporation these these
companies have no oversight the federal
reserve the bank of international
settlements
well because um this is why they say
that
the inflation is let's say running at
1.6 percent even though
if you were to calculate inflation as
you would do under the clinton
administration
and without using all these hedonic
adjustments inflation actually right now
is running 10 to 12 percent
that's the real number 10 to 12 that's
what is really happening is that per
year
per dollar per year so now they say it's
1.6
so why do they openly lie because for
two reasons the
cola adjustments the cost of living
adjustments for social security so they
save about 70 billion dollars a year by
not paying out what they should be
paying out because inflation is going
high
the social security benefits the other
but the primary reason is that by saying
that
inflation is running low and in flat
claiming that there's deflation
they can justify lower interest rates
that are near zero
which are what powers all the
consolidation that tiffany being bought
hopefully is being bought
mergers and acquisition and when i said
earlier about infrastructure crumbling
because of all the debt to finish up on
that point a little bit
it goes back to private equity what
private equity does private equity can
borrow all this money
at near zero percent and buy entire
companies to tie our industries
and strip out all the assets and keep
the profits like uh
um you know being the bain capital uh
mitt romney
uh you know that's his one what's where
he comes from you know we saw it in the
movie wall street in the 1980s right
they were doing a leveraged buyouts as
it was called
uh well that what does that mean what is
that that means that if you have a
company and you want to buy that company
what you can do is and i was working on
wall street when this really became
huge is that you can pledge the assets
of the company that you don't own
to borrow money and then you borrow the
money and you buy the company that you
previously did not own and now that you
own it you start to sell the assets
opposite the pension fund the overfunded
pension account the real estate
all they fire everybody and what's left
and you pay down the debt that you
borrowed
and you keep what's left which could be
100 million or half a billion dollars
that's a leverage buyout
and it was really pioneered by mike
milken
during the 1980s because he he wrote a
paper when he was a wharton
uh where he figured out that the
lower grade debt outperforms high-grade
debt you know so he said you know what
why don't we just do original issue
low-grade debt so ron perlman and all
these other corporate raiders as they
were known they went to mike milken
they borrowed billions they did leverage
buyouts they bought these companies
and they sold they stripped them they
sold all the assets and they became
billionaires well over the last 30 years
that's become bigger and bigger and
bigger
and so the private equity market like
warren buffett is essentially
a private equity firm he doesn't invent
anything he doesn't do anything he never
worked a day in his life
he just borrows money cheap from the fed
strips companies he's an asset stripper
that's all he does
and he's overrated as a mar as a
performer if you take out the bailouts
from the warren buffett performance over
the past 30 years he wouldn't be beating
a money market fund
he's the most overrated money manager in
history so uh people like to say when
we're talking about you know
iras or metal or bitcoin this is not
financial advice
the first thing i want to ask you a
question i haven't given any financial
advice on this program
so so i just wanted to ask real quick
why is that why i would never do that
why would people say
this is not like why do people do that
because you have to be licensed to give
financial advice
and so people can interpret what you're
saying is advice is what it is
yeah because then they could claim that
you were offering advice
and they lost money let's say and then
you're saying okay you
you gave me unlicensed financial advice
but you've you've mentioned
you know that people should buy bitcoin
haven't you yeah because it's not
it's i'm saying bitcoin is a substitute
for gold and it's a substitute for the
dollar
this this came up recently because a lot
of journalists are saying they don't
write about bitcoin
because um they consider it to be a
conflict
in some way because they don't own it
bitcoin they wouldn't own bitcoin and
write about bitcoin et cetera
but we're talking about a substitution
for the base layer of money from dollars
to bitcoin
so it's not at financial advice it's
about advice about how to reconfigure
the entire economy the united states
economy the global economy on a bitcoin
standard uh and so we've been saying
this since it was a dollar back in 2011
and we also talked about gold if you
talk about gold
gold is an intricate part of the global
financial picture so
it countries buy gold the central banks
own 30 000 tons of gold
you talk about gold you can say you own
gold it's an inflation hedge here's a
way to
inflate against inflation is gold so
bitcoin is the new gold it's digital
gold it started in 2011 and we talked
about it
so it's we're making that point that
this is what it is
and that's what we've been saying the
reason i ask is because you mentioned
inflation
was actually at 10 to 12 percent for
real yeah which
shouldn't that like make people act as
other pants are on fire kind of freak
out
that's that's that's scary they should
and they the people who have
with the price of bitcoin at 55 000 per
coin
is telling you that the us dollar right
now is in a hyper inflationary collapse
against
bitcoin that's what the price is telling
you bitcoin is the really the only
market in the world that's allowed to
trade freely
it's not you don't find good price
discovery in gold you don't prime good
price discovery and bonds
you don't find good price discovery in
stock so those markets are not telling
you anything the markets are
rigged whereas bitcoin is a freely
traded market it's telling you something
for real
that the us dollar in the fiat money
world is in a hyper inflationary
collapse right now against
bitcoin that's what the price is telling
you right now that
price should be alarming to people it's
not driven by
speculation it's driven it's the it's
not the bubble
tim it's the pin right right so it's not
the bubble
it's not the bubble tim you ran out of
money here
quick puts them back in so it's it's not
i wondered this
bitcoin isn't going up the dollar's
going down exactly that's freaky i think
it's both
i think a little bit of both probably
yeah well i say
people say bitcoin is volatile but it's
not volatile it's actually
just reflecting the chaos in the fiat
currency market
it's a reflection a true reflection it's
a true mirror of what's happening in the
fiat money world it's not volatile the
dollar is volatile the dollar
is uh in is in deep trouble uh for
multiple reasons and once you lose world
reserve uh currency status
you know you're talking about real
inflation where food and energy goes up
it doubles uh and triples you guys
mentioned so
hold on real quick that means if someone
uh
we're talking about regular americans
many people listen to this show they've
got a savings
maybe maybe they've been working they've
been saving up a little bit as much as
they can to the pandemic
maybe they got a thousand bucks right
over the past six months that that the
value of that thousand dollars is now
the equivalent of like 100 or 200 bucks
before it
like the year before yeah so you can't
buy as much gas with it you can't buy
computers anymore you can't buy anything
with it that's right and if you can't do
anything with it it's not particularly
valuable
but if in november um early november
last year was it bitcoin i was like
10 or like 13 000 i think yeah and now
it's at
60. yeah so it was interesting is i was
reading an article about the price of
lumber
they said 10 worth of lumber last year
is 60
today right and i was like that's really
interesting how it's very similar to
the increase in the cost of bitcoin
that's right meaning the dollar is
probably tanking
exactly that's exactly right the lumber
is a proxy for how bad the dollar is
doing
what are these other commodities isn't
this good for the ultra wealthy
it can be if they're well typically uh
it is because they're
in there are invested in assets that uh
that do well in inflationary
environments
so that's why medigliani would cost 200
million dollars that's why somebody paid
400 million dollars for a da vinci
that's why bitcoins is 55 to 60 000. but
the thing about bitcoin is that it's
accessible to everybody around the world
access to a telephone you don't have to
be go through the gatekeepers
it's funny that now ubs or jp morgan are
now offering bitcoin to their high net
worth individual
clients right and they're going to
charge a big fee didn't didn't jamie
dimon just rag on it like for
decades he still rags on it uh but it
so but they are offering it to their
high net worth individuals uh who aren't
smart enough to just buy it on their own
they're not smart enough to buy another
rich people rarely are smart that's one
thing they don't want to take the risk
i've noticed you know individual
sovereignty is quite difficult you have
to it's it's not
easy to learn how to hold your own
bitcoin so they want to uh sue somebody
if if jamie diamond loses it yeah and
there's the infrastructure the financial
markets in terms of custodianship and
things like that that are important for
the
workings of the day-to-day financial are
being put in place to
now embrace bitcoin so that banks can
have proper custodian of these uh coins
and companies like microstrategy run by
michael saylor can put
billion two billion dollars into it and
legitimately so doesn't this also mean
that people's debt
is going down in value as well say for
instance if you owe
ten thousand dollars in a car and now
hyperinflation hits
everything's more expensive you still
only owe ten thousand dollars yeah yeah
well that's why that's why the
government keeps printing because they
don't want to pay their debt
right that's they're trying to evaluate
their way out of their debt
there's only two ways out of the problem
one is to keep printing
as you just eloquently said or two allow
for a default
in the 30s in 1930s you had a
deflationary depression there was
default whereas in zimbabwe or weimar
germany or america today it's an
inflationary depression and it's because
the powers don't want to give up
they don't want they they they want to
inflate their way out of this because as
you point out
if you're in if you have a lot of assets
the value of those assets are going to
keep
skyrocketing along with bitcoin but a
lot of other assets are like
obviously if you're trading if you have
a massive lumber or things like that
but for the average person though they
don't have assets
so they simply see it reflected in the
price of living and
for food and energy and so their
quality of life it will take a severe
drop it's been pointed out that in the
weimar germany you saw speculative
attacks essentially
from the wealthy against against the
deutsche mark the reichsmark
and that is that they used their
leverage and their ability to borrow
and and racked up huge amounts of debt
and right
and bought things like corporations land
and property
so that that did happen from some
industrialists
in weimar germany and you could say that
is happening today as well that these uh
these corporations
right and wealthy people that's why
amazon is borrowing
tens of billions of dollars right now
because they can and they're going to
buy assets right they're going to buy
assets they're attacking the fed they're
attacking the country
wow right and um they're attacking the
essentially it undermines the dollar
it's not like they're going out and
saying
i'm gonna take this dollar i'm gonna rip
it up they're like uh we see what's
coming
uh an industrialist is going to know
because they see the input costs they
see the cost rising
they understand i i think this is why we
saw so many billionaires
defend china we saw what do you mean
well uh when the hong kong thing was
going on a lot of industries and a lot
of ultra wealthy individuals were like
come on
leave china alone you know we we
shouldn't
well it's just like what we were saying
earlier about everything running on
cobalt
it's like there is a the our
just-in-time
delivery chains you know our supply
chains
it's like we can't unwind it and
that would be the equivalent of them
saying okay we have to reset and start a
whole new thing like
the supply chains they can't reset it
like that that fast so they can't say
anything
right because otherwise the whole thing
will fall apart i mean i i have to i
have to wonder you know they're doing
this
unemployment thing right yeah 16 an hour
equivalent to not work
so so when asked joe uh joe biden and
jen seki were like no that has nothing
to do with why we're seeing 7.4 million
job openings
but only 266 266 000 jobs you know
filled i think it's pretty obvious right
typically i hate not to work
totally obvious she's lying through her
teeth it's completely obvious
and the thing about her is that you've
got a lot of people in america now know
what it's like to live like a hedge fund
manager
do nothing and get free money from the
government buy assets buy stuff
and do nothing that's the way a lot of
rich people they just get
like again buffett or some of these
other folks they are literally welfare
bums
they just get free money from the
government and they don't do anything
they don't add anything to the economy
and so a lot of people are saying you
know what now that i live like ken
griffith who's a hedge fund manager at
citadel who puts ben bernanke on his
board
of directors who gets involved in the
gamestop fandango
who gets bailed out and uses the money
to bail out his subsidiary melvin
capital from the money he got from the
government to bail out the year before
and then does anyone get does nothing
for it
um and people are saying that's the way
i want to live i want to get free money
too and live like
these hedge fund guys i don't want this
to work is is perhaps the game stop
rebellion as it's being called the first
sign of like an actual insurrection
against the system game stop is like
wall street
occupy wall street but deeper so occupy
wall street can never get into side the
system the game stop reddit guys got
into the system they recognized that
gamestop
the stock had been their counterfeit
sales of many shares that
didn't exist the birth they were being
sold naked short selling short selling
so they knew that they could uh bid up
the price and
put this short squeeze on that's amazing
right so i love it
yeah it's it is activist uh it is
like what we call the global
insurrection against banker occupation
giabo so it's a worldwide phenomenon
because the bankers are everywhere
they're doing the same thing everywhere
and all the central banks are working
together
you know when they say in the us and jay
pal will say oh you know actually you
know rates went up a little bit six
months ago and we
we we reduced our asset purchases by two
percent
the fact is on a net basis when you look
at all central banks all the major
central banks around the world for the
last 20 years they've never been in one
single day that they haven't expanded
their balance sheets and done
net purchases of these assets and built
it up but the gamestop thing is working
within that system
gold works within that system like
that's a
you know relentlessly pessimistic sort
of doomed
system where these uh you know the
command and control
people in charge of our economy they'll
never let anybody fight back
they'll never let you protect yourself
and then you see until until it just
falls apart and they will destroy you
but
bitcoin fixes that bitcoin allows you to
just exit
the system as christine lagarde warned
recently she said we must stop bitcoin
because it it's an exit
an escape valve from our system so
you know she's telling you the truth and
that's like you can
you know once you exit that system and
you become relentlessly optimistic as we
are in our telegram group over at orange
pearl podcast
you know we uh you you don't you don't
need to be
um are you looking at my i i i you know
like my christina
oh my my wig my plan was like i thought
i thought i looked like clint eastwood
with my with my poncho
and then i realized clint eastwood
doesn't really you know wait
it's just sweet christina
and premier premier premier julian
do you have a question for her she's
asking she says
yeah yeah that's that's like my life i'm
sorry this is i think
doge is the next step of the rebellion
what we saw the last two months is
people
it's basically like gamestop people just
game the system i don't think it's a
good coin
but i think that's an example of people
but it's a douche unionizing right but
hold hold on i want to sure i want to
talk about the the rebellion
yeah so i mentioned yeah we mentioned
gamestop bitcoin is the only rebellion
gamestop is not a rebellion it's just
like
within the system they control the
system they control the
the sec the the stock market all the
stuff look what happened when can't they
just short sell
games like they stop when it goes up
again what no what happened robin hood
uh
stops yourself right so they control
that system right
and you play by their rules you know the
house wins
robin hood was was was i guess they were
threatened right like robin of the
company was
robin hood it gets their primary source
of revenue
they buy the order flow from robin hood
so they shut them down to protect melvin
capital a subsidiary of citadel
so it's an all rigged situation totally
let's talk about the next thing that
we're seeing this is this is i i gotta
admit
i saw this story and i'm laughing quote
we all quit
restaurant signs claiming staff walking
out are popping up across the u.s
these tweets are something else there's
on chipotle on burger king on wendy's
mcdonald's signs being like we're closed
because no one showed up today
there are signs people putting up saying
we refuse to work for such little wages
right and there's a couple of things for
one we know
biden is basically paying people more
money to not work than they could get
from working
sure but also inflation so if people
you're
you mentioned earlier that people 40 of
their weekly budget is going to food
so if you're working at a fast food
restaurant it doesn't matter if you're
getting 15
an hour or 20 an hour what matters is
how much food can you afford to buy in
the week
at the end of the week they could pay
you a thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars
but if your food costs four thousand
dollars ten thousand doesn't mean
anything
that's exactly right i mean if you can
keep getting your rate wages
raised but the price of food goes higher
than they're raising the wages that
you're getting a cut and pay
so what happens in argentina venezuela
that's what's happening right now they
keep printing like mad but
they can't control inflation and the
policy makers will say there's no
inflation
because their banking constituents want
that
zero percent money to keep consolidating
and mergers and acquisitions and
leverage buyouts so they say it's at one
point six percent
even though it has a patent false but
the supply
the supply situation is going to be
something we can't hide so
you have the shortages of all these
microchips that's affecting all sorts of
of the economy the the problem with
labor is a real
genuine problem and just in the drive up
here we saw hundreds and
hundreds of signs all over the place
begging people to come apply for jobs
even in the middle of a
field like there was a sign domino's
looking for a bunch of drivers
and a sign of advertising for domino's
jobs yeah
they're going to hire cows all right
wait wait wait wait wait
order more vinegar we got to start
buying whatever we can
yeah yeah people start hoarding which
then it feeds an inflationary cycle
then prices go up because but i'll get
the vinegar first i just bought 150
pounds of flour
no no i already i already bought you 100
pounds of flour hey i got 150 more but
it's
that it's that sort of mindset the
mindset the psychology is what is really
important to hyperinflation
or whatever i mean but the other point i
want to make is like i was just
uh retweeted a story a day or two ago
about
um in durham north carolina which is a
pretty big city
outside of raleigh and um they can't
find 911
operators so they're having to divert
they had to admit that they've been
diverting calls to raleigh
uh overnight because there's you know
the economy's been
hollowed out right through private
equity deals cheap money
borrowing and debt so it's been hollowed
out it's just a
shell that's cracking in real time all
that money was stolen
trillions were stolen stolen from the
economy
it's fragile like a an egg shell is
cracking
the people are now on the streets and
the revolution is in the air
so you guys have seen the wolf of wall
street no i
never saw you never saw it but max
worked on wall street
so this was like uh you know in the film
you basically have a bunch of coked out
drugged out wall street guys being like
yeah
stop talking about maps like that and
they're just like
i'm not saying they they know that
they're yeah i'm not selling i'm staying
yeah but but it's like these people know
that they're ripping people off
basically like they're just extracting
access to resources and value from a
system without providing anything to it
that's right
wall street my job on wall street it was
a microcosm of the economy as a whole
so the by word as a stock broker is do
whatever you can to get commissions and
we've got lawyers
there there's no such thing as the rule
of law on wall street
you you get the commission first and if
the feds come
after you you deal with it later you
hire pay the fund you pay fines
you know wall street keeps 90 cents of
every dollar they steal
the right 10 cents goes to the fines or
the great thing about wall street is
that they just change the law
uh for example when uh citigroup bought
travelers it's a big
multi-billion dollar deal they broke the
glass-steagall law that had been in
place since the 30s
they simply retroactively changed the
law and said we're going to change the
law and it
retroactively applies to that deal there
are there are there is no rule of law
on wall street fully it's it's i think
it's just the
the rot goes deeper than this have you
guys ever seen these things they're
called like power bracelets or balance
bracelets
they're they're rubber bands that they
sell for like 30 bucks
and they tell you they say when you wear
it it improves your balance
and they use a trick called the center
of gravity illusion it's really simple
you ask someone to stand with their feet
together and their arms straight at
their sides
you then put your hand on their arm and
pull downward
slightly away from their body they'll
fall over then you put the wristband on
their hand
and then you push slightly into their
body and they won't fall over
but you can actually like hang because
you're pushing towards their center of
gravity
sales people in i would see them in
these malls they'd be doing this trick
and i'm thinking to myself
i know how the trick works you could do
it with a rock you could do with
anything
how are they getting away with selling
rubber bands for 30 bucks and lying to
people
so i looked it up it's very simple
someone will start a company
they'll knowingly defraud people the ftc
would come in and say you gotta you
gotta pay us five million dollars they
go oh no
we only made 10. here's your five here's
your cut and then they take that money
and they do the same thing with a new
company a new entity
and they sell trash products pay their
fine start a new company trash products
and they get you know destroyed shut
down but the government's getting a cut
of it
so instead of actually policing these
companies and saying stop doing this
they're like you know so long as we get
money right it's called the captured
regulator
yeah so the sec and elon musk proved
this brilliantly when
recently he broke some laws and he
openly mocked the sec how about
austin texas when they they banned uber
because they were losing money on the
drunk driving tickets they're like wow
we want people to drunk drive
because we made the police made so much
money from it in the city so
revolutions in the air the system has
been hollowed out
when you guys extracted you guys
mentioned you mentioned derivatives
earlier
what was the history of the creation of
derivatives because that seemed like
part of this hollowing
right so derivatives go back to the
option pricing formula for volatility
that came around during the early 80s
and under the reagan deregulatory
environment you had listed options so
listed options are essentially the first
derivative and product and so this is
simply
an option on the future price movement
of a stock
and it's a big market the options market
and then during the 80s they introduced
financial derivatives up until then it
was
confined to stocks and commodities were
the the futures contracts as
you could say is a derivative so futures
contracts have been around for hundreds
of years it's a way for agricultural
companies to hedge against
um the weather right so they can sell
their product today
just to a speculator and they they're in
there for they they don't have the risk
of
their product arriving to market and
losing everything
because they needed to plant the next
season
but with the financial derivative you
had the s p futures and bond futures and
money market fusion and forex features
so
gave banks the way to speculate on money
itself with in a highly leveraged way
and that was the beginning of financial
derivatives so that's the beginning of
when we have
a global ponzi scheme of banks
essentially
trading on inside information with each
other on
financial shenanigans in a way that was
incredibly
leveraged but you're right in the sense
that
at some point the derivatives market
became bigger than the underlying market
right so the derivatives market should
only be a fraction of the underlying
market
to give you an example of this in the
oil market for every barrel of oil
there's something like 60 000
barrels in oil derivatives right that's
how
leverage this whole thing is for for the
global economy which is let's call it a
100
trillion dollar global economy there's
more than a quadrillion
in derivatives right the quad the
derivatives market is a
multi-quadrillion dollar market so an
example that would be like if a company
loses six million dollars in assets or
something and but people bet
on that they can make 60 million on that
6 million loss in a derivative
well one one great milestone in the
derivative business
was uh the credit default swap invention
by life masters exxon
remember the exxon valdez oil spill yeah
oh yeah uh instead of exxon suffering uh
financial calamity from that
blythmasters invented the credit default
swap where
she was able to strip out bonds from
bond interest and sell the interest
separately essentially
and insulated exxon from that disaster
so they they took the event which would
have been a liability and they turned it
into a non-event
effectively wow so um that's that's just
what we call financial engineering and
it's a
and so you could say that it's a way to
slice and dice securities into
all different things if you go to the
2008 the subprime crisis
was a derivatives crisis because they
took
subprime mortgages which are have a high
probability of defaulting
and they mixed it with a triple a rated
government bond and then they sold that
mixed package as a trash to a pension
fund
with the idea that well th the
probability of this collapsing
is so minute that we're going to give it
the same rating as the bond a triple a
rating
this is like the the housing crisis yeah
they took so what happened well
the first time in history you had a
housing crisis and over the entire
country
and so the subprime market collapsed
spectacularly
and instead of fining or penalizing
the banks that package this garbage even
in testimony
they told congress that these were bags
of expletive
that they were selling the goldman sachs
not only did goldman sachs knowingly and
openly sell
bags of expletives to clients excrement
yes extra mint they then
made bets against their clients knowing
that the clients would blow up
so they made money on the short side
they sold their own clients short to
make money on the collapse of the client
that they knew was going to happen
because they had sold them
the bags of excrement so that's how
insidious and awful
and corrupt the sole system is it's kind
of like encouraging
your wife to go skydiving and then
taking on a massive life insurance
policy on her
and then knowing that she has no idea
right and then selling short the
the air airline company and the
skydiving company knowing that they're
going to be sued out of existence
i have to also point out that you know
while we're talking about inflation this
is the thing that's so topsy-turvy about
everything and why we have um such a
chaos
in our economic system is those
derivatives
are collapsing and that is a black hole
and that is a huge amount of deflation
right
so if that's worth nothing but it's
right now on paper
worth a quadrillion that's a lot of
money that's like many many many many
many many trillions that we'd have to
print every month
just to break even on that right so the
central bank has bought now
trillions of dollars worth of this paper
from wall street eight trillion
eight trillion dollars that they to re
liquefy wall street but that's just a
small fraction of it
right but they buy it at 100 cents on
the dollar but when you say okay what's
the resale value
it's zero so the federal reserve bank
has leveraged more than a hundred to one
which is they're leveraged more than
enron i mean enron was leveraging 80 70
or 80 to one it collapsed in a day
the federal reserve bank has leveraged
much more than enron
it was leveraged and it could collapse
overnight because but that's
that's the problem with the whether or
not it's inflation or deflation and this
is a debate this is
a debate that we've been having on all
of our content
for the last 15 years like nobody
economists
bankers nobody knows for sure what which
one we're actually having
so right i i wanna i wanna i wanna say
one thing and i wanna read you this next
story um i think you're both wrong i
think dogecoin is incredible
i think i think dogecoin is no you're
incorrect
it's douchecoin you wanna know why
you're wrong douchecoin dogecoin has
just made a bunch of people who don't
pay attention pay attention
and if in the end they trade dogecoin
for
bitcoin it's it's it's better isn't it
no i i don't have
attention i've been in this business for
10 years and
and no one knows more about it than i do
and it's
um it's a gateway drug to getting
wrecked
so people think that they are smart
enough to trade altcoins in a way that
they're going to get more bitcoin or
they're just going to be in it for a
minute and
but the fact is that once you step away
from
bitcoin you're entering the gambling
casino so it's the same
if ever you go to vegas and you go
across the
the room with all the slot machines and
you ask 100 people
how if they're winners in vegas 100
people say yeah i win all the time i'm a
big winner
they're sitting there with a smoke and a
cigar you know with thread bear
with nothing on their back and they're
like i've been winning in this for years
and years
because the gambling mentality is such
you convince yourself that you're
you're going to win at this gambling
thing so that's number one i do
and number two the projects themselves
suck uh they're all centralized garbage
bitcoin is decentralized it's a big
difference um
and it you can't compare the two it is
it's i'm not saying dogecoin
technologically or their infrastructure
their code i'm saying a bunch of
regular people young people who had no
interest at all in any capacity
with cryptocurrency all of a sudden now
the door was opened to
at least walking into the room and if at
the end of it
ten percent of the people or one percent
of those people who normally would never
be involved are like
i'm gonna buy bitcoin with it because
that that's that's that's the real asset
so they bought some dogecoin as a joke
it went up they went whoa they sold it
then they you know got bitcoin instead
isn't it better well it's like
bitcoin is is the house and everybody
else are the are the trumps on the floor
so i own bitcoin if somebody wants to go
into the speculative world of gambling
on douchecoins
uh and ultimately all that capital the
size of the market is expanding right so
it's a 2 trillion plus
and that means that ultimately more
money will flow into
bitcoin bitcoin goes through cycles and
right now it's going sideways and it's
building it banks and then it'll make a
big leap again
and then you'll see a rotation out of
all these alt coins into
bitcoin uh and a lot of people will get
wrecked i mean
also when you're trading in those all
kinds there's all kinds of tax
liabilities you have to be aware of
absolutely
uh there's just it's just it's not worth
it instead of just
my shirt huddle huddle baby huddle
that's what it's all about
don't make me get undressed tim don't
make me get naked on your show please
don't get on yourself
i'm not saying dogecoin is better
bitcoin i'm saying dogecoin has a
marketing campaign
got a bunch of people to finally know
what crypto was they're going to get
wrecked so
people who bought it last week on the um
you know elon musk saturday night live
at 72 or 74 cents a
coin they're sitting at 30 or 40 percent
losses today and they're wondering what
the heck am i going to do it's going to
scare a lot of people out they're going
to
they're to not you you enter into the
arithmetic of losing the amount of
percent gain you need to break even once
you lose 10 percent is more than 10
right so uh you know you and then you
what happens is you
tend to to trade riskier
projects as is today there's another
coin that's
today so a lot of people who lost 30 on
doge in the last week are going to be
i'm going to make it back
on this other thing which is even more
ridiculously cool so
they end up with zero let's look let's
let me ask you about bitcoin though if
for one there's a finite amount of
bitcoin it's gonna it's it's not they're
not going to complete the 21 million
uh coins until when do you know what
you're another hundred years another
hundred years yeah
so if if look we we
i was talking with some some of the
people here at tim cast earlier
and one of the suggestions was like why
don't you buy like do a video where you
buy something big with bitcoin and i was
like
because i'd rather have the bitcoin why
would i why would i give it up for
anything
you know tesla says you can buy a you
know a tesla with a bitcoin i'm like i'd
rather have the bitcoin
it's like why would why would i spend a
million dollars on a 50 000 car
yeah bitcoin's gonna hit a million bucks
yeah and i think it's gonna be a lot
faster than most people realize
so i guess the challenge is right now
should people uh
you know uh should hypothetical people
who are working
just be buying as much bitcoin as
possible but keeping some of the fiat
for regular use
rent food because you don't want to
spend the bitcoin you want it for later
that's
right that's right at what point are you
like okay now i can spend bitcoin
when it becomes greater
parity to gold so gold's worth about 10
trillion dollars let's call it bitcoins
worth of 1 trillion or so
when you see bitcoin trading at parity
to gold at around 500 000 a coin or 10
trillion dollars worth
then i think it'll be it'll be
transitioned from
uh the pure only store of value to store
value and medium of exchange it's not
really a medium of exchange
as such although on what's called the
second layer with uh lightning and other
applications built on top people are
using it as uh for transactions every
single day and a lot of people who do
transact in bitcoin that might spend
bitcoin uh let's say a thousand dollars
of the bitcoin they'll immediately buy a
thousand
to replenish that a lot of people the
most intelligent thing you can do is
dollar cost averaging
which is just every single day or every
week or every month you simply put in
10 bucks 100 bucks or a thousand bucks
into uh bitcoin on a regular basis
you know we we work with i think you
know swan bitcoin is a company that
specializes in this and we we we work
with them pretty closely i got
i got an email from someone somebody who
has like a wealthy individual who had a
trust like a wealthy family
yeah and they were talking to their
financial manager or whatever saying we
need to start
putting our assets into bitcoin and they
said absolutely not we won't do that
yeah and so the email i got was like
very upset like what are we supposed to
do
well that's that's understandable the
the entrenched you know the the
establishment in these markets don't
want to the competition
and they don't want people taking money
out because once a lot of people
understand that
you know the saying goes not your keys
not your bitcoin you take the keys off
these exchanges and these products and
you and so you're taking money out of
the system
so for if you're uh somebody who's
business is accumulating assets under
management aum
and that's a negative for you because
people are taking all their assets off
and they're
they're putting into cold storage and so
that's that's just
they don't want that competitive thing
going on and the the amount of money
made on selling products is enormous
and this is uh up there's no fees
attached
it's it's it's free to store essentially
uh
so they don't want the competition and
but
uh that is changing quite rapidly as
paul tutor jones very famous hedge fund
manager said
he believes inflation is here and he he
owns a lot of gold
but he says bitcoin is the fastest horse
in the race
um how long until you think bitcoin
reaches
half a million well i i haven't got a
price target for 20
21 of 220 000 per coin
why what what was it based on the
halvings that we've had
every four years we've had three
halvings and uh
typically you see these types of price
moves in the the year
yeah that's that's cyclically what we
say what's the happening well so once
again uh
has has the price tracked as you've
predicted it thus far
because i know that's yeah the first
quarter it did it did very very well
now it's kind of going sideways and i
think we're going to see in the
second quarter another breakout move to
to you know in
70 80 85 000. so i've known you guys for
a decade
and uh i i told you the story of bitcoin
back in 2011 i was at a hackerspace in
l.a it was called crash base i was
hanging with my friend jeff
and i were sitting on my computer i had
savings i had about five grand in
savings i had worked i had saved it i
never gonna touch it it's my rainy day
fund it's like i'm very proud i was you
know
was like 24 or something and i said i
saw bitcoin
so the bitcoin faucet for those that
aren't familiar there's a website that
literally just gave you free bitcoin it
was point zero five i believe
could be wrong just randomly like there
you go here's some because it was almost
worthless
so i look at my friend and i'm like
should i just buy a bunch of this
bitcoin thing
because i'm just saving this money it's
sitting in a bank
you know i got to pay fees or whatever
why don't i just buy this bitcoin and he
goes
ah nah dude like it's probably scam
you're going to buy it off some dude and
then it's going to become worthless and
i was like
yeah i guess not and so i was actually
no joke sitting there about to buy like
7 300
you know bitcoin yeah at 70 cents and
then i remember when i went up to five
bucks
and i was like oh man remember when i m
when jeff when you told me how to buy
then hit 20 bucks same story then it hit
500 same story
and what's funny is so i remember when
you guys were promoting bitcoin like
crazy
and i was just watching it like yeah but
now it's at you know five bucks
if only i had bought was a dollar now
it's at 60
000 and i'm like why didn't i listen to
max well
that story is the exact same story that
peter schiff has experienced
yeah but he's still i told him about a
dollar i told him about ten dollars i
told him about a hundred dollars i told
him a thousand dollars tell him about
ten thousand dollars and he still
won't buy it he's still anti-bitcoin
he's still saying the same
silly things over and over again i have
been common story
i was buying though so so you know what
i like
i'm like man i should have bought i'll
buy some i'll buy a little bit but i
never went
gung-ho i never went full in i just
bought a little bit here and they're
like oh well i'll just have some
well it's never too late you know this
it's it's going to continue to go up you
know
on this financial advice question it's
like
we're setting the table we're saying
look here's inflation here's your
options
here's what people are saying you know
and make your own choices do your own
research
but it's a very compelling story uh
and and given that what the track record
has been
and nothing we've said that would happen
hasn't happened
pretty much we've been absolutely spot
on in predicting
the last 10 years pretty much every
major turn in the global economy i'm
definitely going to be buying uh more
bitcoin but what
bitcoin what do you think about ethereum
though it's a centralized garbage
you don't like aetherium [ __ ] nah that's
fine
well so i'm not going to pretend that
ethereum is the same thing as bitcoin i
think so it's centralized it's it's got
it's the transactions are reversible
they've reversed transactions before
60 pre-mine is the it's an exit scam
where metallic and those guys are just
dumping coins whenever they feel like it
um it's uh it's not robust at all it's
uh buggy
it's never been nobody knows how many
exist
you say what you can't run a note what
is it ethereum
exactly what is it like what's the point
of it
so there's there's applications run off
of it using erc20 tokens
right so like why not use microsoft why
not use aw yeah
all of the all of the nobody run nobody
can run a node it costs too much
it's all hosted on aw aws that's true
so you can shut it down do you think uh
do you think aws is going to listen
you know to vitalik buterin or are they
going to listen to the treasury if the
treasury contacts them no
i i agree so i i think i view ethereum
as is very very different from bitcoin
it's more of like an investment into a
company
yeah bitcoin and if there are a lot
better companies than to invest in this
but if you're i don't know but if your
objective is to
what everything that that bitcoin offers
as we've discussed about it and that's
your objective there's there's bitcoin
if you want to get involved in something
called ethereum which is some software
that is
buggy and it's centralized and it has a
track record of malfeasance
that's an option people i want to be
medici i want to be my own bank i want
to be the central bank i want to have
my own country within me and i don't you
know bit ethereum doesn't give that no
other coin gives that just bitcoin
are you saying you've invested in
nothing other than bitcoin that's all we
did yeah nothing else
you guys should create points no you
can't it's like
like as soon as there's an individual
who can be identified
and that person can then take the coin
down
the treasury contacts yeah i think that
that's centralized i think the future of
currency is like
you make max coin stacy coin ian coin
and then
well hear me out hear me out no i had a
question i asked that i was
you guys are not investing in anything
outside of bitcoin like so we have we
have bitcoin and we have invested in
uh bitcoin startups like for example
kraken
which is an exchange when it was five
million dollars we invested in it it's
now
uh worth uh 10 billion dollars
swampbitcoin.com four slash orange
pillow we
we find we spawn them yeah we finance
them
no like regular stocks of like you know
blue chips or
five hundreds or anything um no because
um we there's a couple of interesting
companies that are bitcoin related
so microstrategy has a big bitcoin
position
square which is jack dorsey's company is
really a big on the bitcoin vanguard
so i have positions i have small
positions in these in these uh
in these companies that are bitcoin
related uh investments
in uh what year was it was 2012 i was
hanging out with you guys and i was i
was
filming for some show and yes you guys
you were filming some guy
some rich guy and he was like you got to
buy square and squares like 13 bucks
yeah
and so i was you know i was mostly broke
and i was like all right i'll buy some
and i did not regret it oh good so i i
tell these stories about like i wish i
bought bitcoin but the reality is
just standing next to you guys hearing
you guys talk about square
right and then actually and squares up a
lot oh yeah especially from back then
square is huge
so uh for those that are familiar with
when i went on the on the joe rogan
podcast with jack dorsey
i said before we start the show like i
should do a disclaimer that i own some
shares and square not that much
like very very little because i was
broke when i bought into it yeah but now
it's like
yeah well we have some gold and silver
from our gold and silver days but we use
it as collateral to buy bitcoin
wow so what do you mean collateral like
taking out loans
that's the way uh wealthy people do it
right you don't want to pay taxes
because as soon as you sell anything you
have to
you have to do your capital yeah we
started buying gold at the 400 range if
you borrow
again so so you go to a bank what do you
do you you say like hey i want 100
to buy bitcoin and you buy bitcoin in a
month go to a bank yeah you put up your
gold and silver's collateral and you
take out a loan
so then a month later because bitcoin's
just skyrocketing you just pay back the
loan and then you got free bitcoin
you pay it back out of your earnings
like whatever so you don't have to
uh pay the capital gains right on block
fi you can put crypto up as
as collectible yeah it's a huge market
but um
but you do have to give up your keys
yeah yeah yeah i give it that so
it's not worth it if dollars are going
down
and we're like man is this bad and
bitcoin is going up this is great
yeah and you can go to a bank and
they'll say we will give you the dollars
to buy bitcoin yeah
that seems like a no-brainer yeah that's
right
gold and silver are going up and so is
the bitcoin
right so my collateral is going up as
well as what about property though
property's good
property is a sitting duck because you
have property taxes which are going to
go up and you can't
it's also not very you know i think it's
going to be it's not liquid
bad times when you have what i think is
going to be a very troubling
uh time and you need to move and and
leave
let's say the country for example you
can't really take your property but you
can't take your bitcoin you just need
memorize a seat phrase and you can go
through the airport naked
and you can have any amount of bitcoin
but it is with you
but it's uh i mean you want to have you
don't want to just only have bitcoin
right you won't have other things i'd
imagine
like you want to maybe focus heavily on
bitcoin but i'd imagine well what
happened over the last 10 years is that
the since the price went from a dollar
to 55 000
it has now become uh
dwarfed everything else in the portfolio
we invest
invest in yourself that's the best thing
absolutely
like better than any stocks or whatever
because you know as
as you see like somebody somebody like
biden can come along and say
okay capital gains is not 20 it's going
to be 43
and you're like dude i heard it like
exactly i i heard a great quote earlier
today though they said um
when when it all hits the fan and a
bitcoin is worth a million bucks
yeah do you know how many bullets it
would cost to get to get a million
dollars in bitcoin
one right not necessarily not with a
multi-sig wallet
so you have a multi-sig wallet in cold
storage then no no i'm not a bullets can
get your bitcoin
yeah yeah but you get the point you know
well the the famous five dollar wrench
attack
the five dollar wrench attack yeah yeah
yeah so but that's
that's that but it i would say in an
extremist
bitcoin is probably the most secure
because um
gold and silver can easily be
confiscated by the government or stolen
and it's
tough to ensure and keep in a vault then
you have your house can be
taken away as the houses have been taken
away yeah money can be cancelled
once you put money in the bank you know
technically it's owned by the bank
you don't own it right more right so
that's the capital gains that can read
your mind
right so with bitcoin it's actually in a
total breakdown it's the only
form of wealth which is actually secure
how about so how about all the money
that uh
police deal across america uh uh
civil assets people say oh what if
electricity goes down well actually now
bitcoin is being beamed via satellite
from block stream so you don't need the
electrical grid to be working you can
you can set up a bitcoin password that's
just like a regular old password you
remember right
you can do yeah so you can create a
phrase that's really easy for you to
remember but really hard for a computer
to correct like a 12 to 24 word phrase
yeah yeah so i always tell people like
good passwords it's like a song lyric or
something or
just a sentence usually you get a random
word generator which you can find online
and they just
generate random words but that's not
better than it can be because
the i believe in in this case the best
place to go for information about that
is called bitcoin.page and that is run
by jamison lop and he's like
one of the top security experts in the
space so you know i
i wouldn't take your uh security advice
from uh
you know from us right now i would go to
the top guy jameson lop bitcoin.page and
it has all the security stuff how to
how to create the best uh passphrases
and all that yeah yeah definitely let's
uh let's talk about the revolution
yeah let's do it we got this we got the
story from fox news lapd station
firebomb attack caught on camera
as suspect tosses molotov cocktail at
building
suspect taken into custody lapd to panga
division station but motive unknown
that's just the story it could be
nothing i mean you guys have certainly
heard of stories like this throughout
your
your your right you're seeing more and
more of this and um with bitcoin it's
peace
peace peaceful it's it promotes love and
promotes uh
community whereas fiat money this is a
fiat money story this is what happens
when when you have a an economy this is
what happens when somebody works for 80
hours in a week
and then says i need to pay my rent and
then a month goes by and he can't afford
to buy food even though he just worked
80 hours it's happening because money is
literally just paper
this happens when uh you know
disintegrations happen
when the entropy happens within a system
that you see it all the time like
like world wars happen and it's not just
world war pandemic happens at the same
time
you see before the renaissance at the
end of the dark ages you see
bubonic plague you see the inquisition
you see all sorts of stuff start to
happen at the same time because
we're vibrating as a culture and a
people things are going crazy
what's weird we got we got another story
i just got to read this
officers fatally shoot man who rammed
his suv into massachusetts police
station
d.a says so this is just from today this
afternoon
uh the man managed to drive through the
steel double doors he was
he was the officer shot the suspect
appeared to be a man in his early 20s
after he got out of his vehicle and
aimed what appeared to be a rifle at
responding officers
no one was hurt the man was taken to
saint vincent hospital uh
in worcester where he was pronounced
dead on monday the worcester county
district attorney identified the man as
zachary richardson a leicester resident
so i don't know um if we have anything
on this guy or what his motivation was
but regardless look we we we see these
stories and i think it's fair to say
maybe they're just random attacks if we
can't read the guy's mind we don't know
but i think everything you've mentioned
the signs we're seeing pop up at all
these restaurants where people are
refusing to work
people are ready to explode they're
they're they're they're livid
and i really do think when you look at
gas prices going up there was this video
i retweeted it where there's a guy
he felt he's got 20 gallon tank 89
dollars and he's like yo
joe biden what up all right i'm ready to
vote again
and i'm like well look the bill comes
due
you print all this money what do you
think's going to what's weird is that
people
seem to claim that the problem is what
we could fall
under the category of social justice
right for some reason
the policy makers in washington think
the problem has to do with
that's the trick pronouns or something
like that whereas the problem is the
paper money but they don't will never
address this problem
because they themselves are the chief
beneficiary of the graft
i think of the grift of the ponzi scheme
i think you guys know this
occupy wall street was legitimate early
on you had conservatives libertarians
the left
left and right complaining with the big
banks you had the tea party movement
upset with the politicians
you had people ready to storm onto wall
street
angry and then all of a sudden within a
couple of weeks
the protest narrative started switching
into white privilege
uh progressive stack racial hierarchies
and i would be willing to bet
um i'm not saying it's true that special
interests were like how can we get them
to stop pointing the finger at us
introduce race politics make make the
poor people point at each other instead
of at the big banks the financial
institutions
and the corrupt revolving door policies
of the government and then all of a
sudden what happened conservatives
started leaving the libertarians left
right away
and it became a woke fest where people
were like the white people can't speak
anymore and then people lost interest
well look who's the most demonized of
all
in all of this the economic bottom the
ones who've been harmed the most
from this uh us dollar reserves from the
chief and dilemma
from the facility strap like we've
demonized
that and they're called fascists and
they're called uh white supremacist
nazis uh uh you know the the ordinary
and it's like some fat truck driver from
something yeah
so they're the ones that are demonized
because they don't want
they want you to point at the victim as
that's the person
um that that you know rather than this
economic system
it's funny how many of these leftists
who you know i used to i've known many
of them stacked by wall street
they post this this cartoon where
there's three people sitting at a table
there's a rich guy with a big stack of
cookies a working-class guy with like
two cookies
and then a poor person with like one
cookie and he's like that guy wants to
steal your cookies
to make them fight each other and i'm
like how do they recognize this and then
simultaneously defend massive
multinational corporations
cheer on the fbi and joe biden it's like
all of a sudden
the tribe was more important than
anything that ever presented well you've
got a good perspective on it because you
were kind of came out of that
and so did lee camp that's right and and
uh you know
and so he is uh voicing these concerns
every single day in his show luke
rutkowski who we know
he's a guy who was there with his camera
and doing brilliant investigative
journalism on the scene journalism
you know but everyone in the new media
space or the alt media space
uh also marginalized also pushed to the
side
uh and for this for the same reasons
because they
the light will does not want to be
shined
on the actual underlying root causes of
these
problems and so what we do is similar
to that alt-right yeah we focus on the
money issue that's what we've been doing
for
16 17 years and we've been saying this
and nothing we've said has ever been
not been borne out by bio by the truth
you you guys said that the millennials
are gonna have a great century yeah and
that the gen z
but uh the fourth turning may be upon us
we're seeing people attack police
stations
we're saying police quit and mass are we
not going to see
a period of tumult of violence and cast
before it gets better
um we have the cable news which is
different
from back in the 1960s or 70s but look
at documentaries about when max was like
a little kid
there were like a thousand fire bombings
of of
government buildings from the weather
underground and
other groups like that the the sybanes
liberation army
like it was crazy was there was there
multi-factional violence targeting each
other
no they were targeting the government
right now but now it's people against
people because of course uh
we don't you know it's essentially the
same co-intel pro sort of situation you
turn the people against each other
that's the best way to control them so
i've talked about um
civil war yeah and i always preface this
with it was it was the
princeton professor who said we're in a
cold civil war it was you know the
atlantic and new york meg who mentioned
that their high probabilities
you have thucydides trap you have the
fourth turning and what people need to
understand
about the civil war is that americans
often imagine the american civil war as
their reference for what civil war is
it's not
so we recently had someone understand if
it happens here it'll be more like syria
you'll get maybe 24 or 30 factions
totally unrelated
fighting with the government and
fighting with each other in areas
there'll just be chaos and bombings and
shootings
and it kind of feels like hopefully i'll
say hopefully
doesn't happen but we're already seeing
the seeds planted of this we're seeing
various cells of antifa groups with
different names they call themselves
different things in different parts of
the country
but they coordinate with each other to
go after mutual enemies you then have
right-wing militia groups
we we recently had in in portland an
armed group
of of you know fringe leftists marching
around with
full blackout gear body armor a couple
of them in full blackout with body armor
and rifles
and they were blocking traffic
essentially doing patrols a guy gets out
you guys
they start banging on his truck he tells
them you know get out of the way
they have weapons they draw on him
according to him so he
they they uh he gets out of the truck he
thought he hit something someone goes in
they smash his windows they grab one of
his left leaf less lethal weapons
so he warns them he pulls his gun out at
low ready and says the next person that
aims at me i'm going to shoot
he's he gets put in the hospital with
some serious injuries he's got two
broken vertebrae
so these groups are in seattle and
portland it's getting nuts
and you know people are on an edge this
one guy got shot twice in the chest by
one of these leftist guys
and of course you've got right-wing
groups you've got the people strumming
the capital
i think we're walking between the doors
of
different factions of disparate
ideologies some that agree with others
and some that don't
ready for for each other the
institutions that help or the glue to
hold the country together the education
institution education has been destroyed
by debt and being overpriced
so education is now no longer available
to the masses anymore it's become a
privileged
amount for a few and then you have
healthcare became financialized
commodified and it's
unaffordable or it's totally messed
around with
you have the infrastructure is breaking
down and all these institutions why are
they so fragile why did this all happen
because they've been hollowed out
with these private equity groups in wall
street using all the leverage buyout and
the debt
and the funny money and now we're seeing
the reaping the whirlwind
of 40 years of but the scary thing is
it's kind of like belfast what you're
describing there if you've ever been
there and
understand the story there and it's
still going on like you still see
some stuff happening there that the
militia groups
um max and i were there right during the
g8 and obama
obama kicked us out of our hotel by the
way we had to move to a different hotel
luke rutkowski was there and uh filmed
films for us there
and um you know we went by uh they
they did up that street one of the one
of the protestant areas loyalist areas
and you know they closed down the
militia pubs
except for it was i think it was udf at
this one
it was like um for sale they were trying
to clean up the militias and
like after the good friday agreement and
it there was a huge sign on the outside
of this building
for sale and right next to it
handwritten
not for sale property of the udf so
nobody bought it in the
in the eight years it was for sale
because they're like okay i'm not going
to
get firebombed by that but that's but
they're like again like it's still going
on the troubles are still going on it
starts
nominally with like protestant versus
catholic and
you know the queen versus like
independent ireland and
and the same thing here it's like it
starts off like low-key
like msnbc versus fox and then it's like
this weird movable feast that there's no
one thing you could stick your finger on
it's
like changes what their ideology is or
what the word that is a trigger word
that's going to get you
knifed in some alley right so you know
what you know what's really scary to me
is that
you know uh two years ago i said things
are going to get bad yeah and then
a lot of things i said we're gonna have
to happen in january we had our our
friend jack murphy who comes on the show
every other wednesday
uh he was our i think he was our first
guest um we we talked about predictions
for the year and
we got some things eerily right a bunch
of fans of the show were like look at
these clips from your show in january of
last
year that's freaky and uh it's funny
because it feels like we're frogs in a
pot with the water slowly coming to a
boil
as much as i've been talking about so
much of this it's like every day it
seems like more and more is happening
that makes it feel like we're actually
we're in it and it's getting worse and
the scary thing is to realize
we're not wrong well it's media pressure
i don't know if it's necessarily getting
worse or just seems like it's getting
worse
it's definitely by design they want us
to think it's getting worse so we don't
focus on
my facebook page which is a great uh
barometer for me and has always worked
well
um and i like for 2016 i could see that
trump was going to win based on what
what i was seeing i have like half my
family is democrat
and like really democrat and half the
family is republican and will only vote
republican and of course
the republican side of our own military
and police and the other side are all
like academics and
wiccans and stuff like that and
um the the the democrat side is like
vicious now it's it's impossible to go
on my facebook page because
if one of my republican family like
leave a message like oh i voted for
trump
and it's just like an avalanche of all
my like left-wing friends my
democrat friends are just like you nazi
and i'm like this is my facebook page
it's my family but
what's scary is that those people can't
explain themselves no
and i i we talk to conservatives all the
time who have
i mean there's a wide range of political
ideologies outside of
this tribalist trump deranged and now
without trump it's even creepier
because i don't even know what they're
mad about at this point they're still so
mad
and and so like it's a it's a terrifying
anger it's
it's the sort of anger where like you
justify
all sorts of stuff like with that sort
of thing it's fascistic i mean these
people are cheering on the fbi and
george w bush yeah
that scares me i know hackers from back
in 2010 2011 people i was hanging out
with
who were anti-establishment people who
were were out in front of jails because
their buddies had been arrested by the
feds for non-crimes
people who had had thrown parties no
joke
hackers who threw parties for white
nationalists
because they were hackers who were
anti-establishment these people today
are cheering on the federal government
yeah they're they're cheering for law
enforcement they're they're
pro-establishment
they're pro-democrat they're joe biden
and i'm like
what happened to those people to where
they've thrown away any semblance of
principle or ideology and just said
whatever the establishment says goes
because they
fear it's all going to be taken away so
he's talking about the elites coastal
elites the media elites
they never had a moment as they have now
for many years
where people with pitchforks and torches
are outside
their home and they're protesting and
they are frightened because it was very
very cozy for decades
to just be behind a wall and to be an
expert or a pundit or a part of the
elite
and suddenly that's all being ripped
apart and they
are frightened to death so they're
they're
so they're calling the fbi and saying i
know that i protested you
for years and i know that i don't i'm
against the invasiveness and the law
breaking that you're committing along
with
projection but i'm not talking about
rich people i'm talking about people who
slept on the ground at occupy wall
street
yeah i'm talking about people who are
like 20 years old had had 10 bucks to
their names said the system is broken
and we're living on the streets are now
pro-establishment pro-fbi
and so so when when the fbi raided
giuliani's office
i see all these posts from these these
these activists these hackers and these
you know
and they're saying they're cheering and
they're celebrating they're posting beer
emojis and clapping
and i said whoo go fbi go go centralized
federal government law enforcement
and i was like it's so great to see how
you guys have been completely
de-radicalized
i was worried about you for a minute
listen it's it's projection it's also
look on
on the one side you have 90 000 overdose
deaths last year
in america that's on the one side on the
other hand side that's the same
sort of thing that's that's a that's an
abused person that's somebody who's
abused and needing like
um their violent father to come smash
somebody's head in for them like you
want the
needing a thug to beat somebody up or to
remove their
um freedom like that's like that's
something wrong
that's something like mentally
psychologically wrong with you
and i think there's we're an abused
population
from uh you know so what you're talking
about there would be a mass psychosis
yeah it's a psychological uh problem
right
like this like what happened with
germany why did germany go like that
what they were humiliated right they
were humiliated population post-world
war one
well we're a humiliated population as
well here
and i think um you know we have these
two
msnbc versus fox and they're like
pushing the two well
msnbc's ratings are totally in the
gutter now like a fraction of foxes but
it's not it's not just fox it's just i i
i think they're even if you watch fox if
you're getting like tucker carlson
you're getting a this more discerning
world
view albeit far from perfect but tucker
does have on
opposition personalities no one else
does this no
we we do got to jump to super chats
though and take some questions from the
audience so
if you haven't already smash the like
button smash it
smash it and uh comment down and uh go
to timecast.com become a member we'll
have a bonus segment coming up there for
members only after the show so make sure
to check it out and
like share and subscribe to this channel
all right joe howard says
i live in ga not far from athens the gas
went up like crazy
already wow yep yep yeah well we have to
drive back tomorrow so hopefully
so hopefully it'll stay pretty
comfortable get up get up get get
the tragedy is that the government
claims that there's no inflation
because they are take two two cans of
gas and put them in your trunk make sure
you got some
my plan is i have triple a i have the
the plan that gives me a hundred mile
toe so
if as long as we can make it to a
hundred mile radius and we do we have
enough
to get assuming the guy in the triple a
tow truck has any gas yeah
all right it's meta gun griffin says tim
razorfest the ragerholic said he
wouldn't mind coming on your show he is
super
knowledgeable on the communists in fact
the democrat party going back to the
1950s
would be great to have him on um
absolutely big fan of razorfest
would be would be great jack o'neill
says tim
are you aware there are baked in ads for
robin hood and facebook on your podcast
releases lately it's not a good look
uh i am it's the same as on youtube
there's automatic ads
uh take it from them take it i mean my
attitude is always like i'll take look
if if we do a whole show where we're
like facebook is bad yeah and then they
pay
ad money to make us fund us in saying
they're bad
i'm not worried about my audience being
like i heard what tim had to say but
that ad from facebook really convinced
me uh no but look
uh on youtube and on the podcast we have
like a general ed role
right so right you know i guess it is
what it is
maybe you know what we can try and
figure out something we can try and
figure out something for members
the problem is people need to understand
the members only stuff is really really
expensive
because we are paying the bandwidth
costs for all of the teamcast.com stuff
so we're talking tens of thousands of
dollars so
uh ads they happen you know that's
happened
yeah ads happen that's a good thing but
but i got to say it's a good logo
i'm pretty confident in the mental
fortitude of the people who listen to
the show
so yeah this is the most mentally
fortitudinous
audience one can find i i actually think
that's true though
you know that story we started off with
about the gasoline pipeline the gas
pipeline is just like
who clicks on those freaking links that
these uh scammers send like
yeah after so many decades like how do
you do it
well it's actually really simple uh the
the hacker will take a usb
with the virus on it and they'll throw
it in front of the door of the building
yep that's it
employees this is this has always been
the go-to for
absolutely so you would put you would
pick up a usb
oh no i wouldn't because i understand
so you know people have tried sending us
discs or memory cards the first thing
we have a rule here if we ever get a
package of the memory card in it we
office space it
you know you know you've seen office
space sledgehammer
right uh you've got to be insane to put
a foreign memory card in
your machine but what they used to do
back in the day is the uh with floppy
disks
they you they would just throw a floppy
disk in front of the bank and then
somebody pick oh i wonder what's on it
oh my god another thing is there was a
guy who told me that
they would have a cd with viruses on it
and they would hand it out like a music
cd but yo yo check out my tunes free
music free music
and people would be like cool and they'd
put it in their machine and then
compromised
so people are trusting but you got to
understand too
it's really really easy to do um
because if you read about social
engineering
yeah it's which is 99 of all hacks it's
not someone breaking the computer it's
someone tricking another person
yeah i mean it's it's extremely easy to
embed a remote access tool into
any kind of program they even put it in
pdf files someone send you a pdf saying
like here's the invoice
thanks for doing business with us and
what person is going to they're going to
be what's the invoice they're going to
open it boom they got you
i've received those i never downloaded
it
[Music]
we have that under our youtube all the
time the reply the
the scammers who look like you they
right there the imposter one
but but they can't because of the
algorithm put here's our whatsapp number
they have to do like
here's our whatsapp slash what
and like somebody has called it like
somebody uh contacted and said i called
the guy
and he put he was nigerian but he put on
a fake american accent to sound like max
and he played a video of me but he
wouldn't get on this
jesus that's great all right we got josh
from telegram he says tim look into
crypto based charity governance tokens
the actor who played stan in the office
is starting one for actors
maybe you can do one for animal
surgeries or a to a legal fund
ps and i get it ian is this is this
graphene-related mug next
wrong we were talking about graphene
earlier yeah we were talking about
the planned obsolescence of society and
now the fiat
overwhelm coming up and so basically
they they made our roads to break every
eight years
and then we were just supposed to take
out some money and pay it and then we'd
get create jobs but now the
interest is so high we can't afford to
build it no back
and we need something like a new
material built back better plastic's not
good enough steel's not good enough
copper's not good enough wood's not good
enough we need graphene
all right let's come here but don't
create a uh token build back better with
graphene
eastside tony says tim call joe rogan
and get max and stacy on his show
and then five exclamation points
definitely sup max and stacy defend the
network
bitcoin get you on the line right now
joe how you been buddy how's austin
i spoke with tim right now say hello you
guys have never been on joe's show
no no it surprises me actually that
surprised me but uh i definitely can't
just call joe rogan and be like here's
you know your recommendations for the
week we we would
gladly do tim cast but that joe fella
i'm not so sure
you know i don't know who needs you know
200 million that guy
yeah but he's has his audience declined
since he went to spotify
like i we we wanted to watch he
interviewed somebody recently where i
was like oh
i'm going to go to youtube i googled it
and it was like only clips
i was like oh that sucks i'm not going
to sign up for spotify i already have so
many
yeah who needs like like like like like
like like like like like it's free on
spotify though it is oh but you need an
account don't you yeah you need an
account
i just made it two week two days ago
three days ago he had the guy talking
about aliens on
from the government was that the guy
you're talking no no i it was somebody
like elon or i definitely think his
views have probably gone down
a whole lot it's like howard stern you
know he went over to sirius and he just
like lost his
relevancy and cachet as well
uh joe's cool guy he's a friend and
i'll say this when he was on itunes
itunes being the biggest podcast
platform yeah when you're number one
a regular person who's never listened to
a podcast before opens up the podcast
app
and your face pops right up right that
is real estate you cannot pay for it
yeah yeah
and so spotify paid for it they
basically
gave joe enough money to where he was
happy doing his show but but also i
think
you know i wonder too if uh does joe
need to be the biggest podcast in the
world i mean i mean it's personally
because i'm wondering
i can't read the guy's mind and i'm sure
you know you know i'd probably just ask
him about it
but uh at a certain point you don't want
to be the big the biggest
you know player in the room because he
keeps getting attacked by the media
totally i'm sure he's happy to be like
dude i just want to hang out with my
friends and talk about things i find
interesting without being harassed by
these people all the time
so yeah but those paid wall you know
those
you know this whole motto of washington
post and new york times and this
breakdown that's happened
since 2016 of of like
attacks on alt media and and that uh we
need
trusted sources authoritative sources
and then you go to like the washington
post it'll be like
urgent thing about election safety and
security and all this sort of stuff
democracy dies in darkness
here uh you have to you have to
subscribe and you're like okay
well i guess i don't need to hear the
story right people don't uh
you know it just stops you dead in your
tracks because you just don't want to
fill
in the details for yet another no way
all right uh
i'm gonna answer this before i read it
i'm just gonna say this word real quick
bitcoin okay now i'm gonna read it
rudy c winslow says max stacy i want to
dump 1500
into crypto which ones should i invest
in all right now this is where that
thing about
the caveat about financial advice comes
in like i wouldn't tell you where to put
that money
because i would be giving financial
advice i will say that
this is what my believe is the story is
with bitcoin and this is what i think
about the douche coins
and then you make your own decision i'm
not going to tell you what to do
because that would be giving a financial
advice but i'll set the table and i'll
tell you
my thoughts on here you know my thoughts
on here but that's up to you
to make your own decision uh i i i
everything max said i'm saying as well
so you can't you can't ask somebody else
what to do
whenever i go to casinos i can't stand
it people like what should i bet and i'm
like oh i'm not playing that game
right right right no way but then
sometimes like i'll be like dude bet on
this one better right now and then when
they lose the money i'm like ugh i'm not
paying back
like i made you do it i can't do it you
you just
you just dollar cost average into
bitcoin
and set it and forget it and don't get
don't
don't fall into the trap of trying to be
a professional trader and
getting into the douche coins and plus
uncle jack
uncle joe will be sending us more money
soon don't worry uncle joe the money's
coming
from joe you guys are going to love this
m says
uh she got listed on binance today and
binance ran out of eth deposit addresses
because so many people wanted it
the coin is top 20 on coin market cap
right now up 2
000 past week right don't forget ever
she
owner needs a leash right that's okay
finance is a casino operator
yeah and so is coin um base and so
are these other exchanges they're like
they are casino operators and they list
it's like listing the number seven on a
roulette wheel
as a thing that you can dump money on
that's yeah that's that's what this is
that's nothing to do
and you know and you know what people do
and i i've actually started blocking
people on twitter
i'll tweet something like totally
nonsensical yeah i bought it i made a
cheeseburger today and i put
cheddar on it and at the top the
immediate comment is this coin is going
to the moon right
and i'm like get out of here so my
theory is
as well that you know i especially with
guys i think a lot of guys use it as a
bonding to
get wrecked together like you know that
tv series jackass or something
they like to just like yeah you know you
ever see those videos for darwin award
it's always guys right young guys doing
something really stupid
and i think i i think they genuinely if
you've ever been in the um
the troll boxes on like btce which is a
old exchange that is now dead there was
a whole bunch of guys it was like it was
this i lost a bunch of money
yeah yeah they were there they were like
dude i just lost my house
my mom you know i guess i had i had
bitcoin on this yeah and then it went
yeah yeah yeah it's gone but um
i think they do it for the lulls just
like remember back in the days when
and you know anonymous existed and they
were all the
the lulls truck what was it lol's little
the the lol sack yeah a little sec yeah
and then they all got thrown in jail
right
well they had a traitor yeah and then
yeah and then they were like uh this
isn't fun anymore right exactly
and the thing is that everyone's having
a lot of fun and they get wrecked and
then they're not as fun anymore it's
like wall street then they launched
wall street bets what about like how
they would post like i just
put you a hundred grand into this
ridiculous stock yeah it's like
zero and they're like well there it goes
yeah yeah yeah well that's portnoy did
that too
dave know what he an interesting
phenomenon on the day you should not
have sold huh what do you do
he's a 700 000 loss on gamestop stock
meme stocks
oh because he sold yeah he's a classic
example of somebody who
confuses brains with a bull market right
so
he stepped into a bull market he's
making some fast money
and you start to think that it's because
you're smart then
he loses he he the winklevoss talked him
into
uh bitcoin plus a douchecoin he lost
quick he's he sold out lost money and
then he tries to make it up
by going into doggy coin to make it up
because he's now he's a gambler
right now he's trying to make up for and
get it back quick you know you know my
favorite thing is
when bitcoin hit 20k for the first time
yeah and there were these stories
emerging where people were like i
mortgaged my home to buy bitcoin
yeah and then when it tanked down to
like 10 they panic sold
right and if they held onto it they'd
have cleared everything
right leverage is always a bad idea yeah
there's no point in going into leverage
i mean i i realize i did
mention i collateralized my gold and
silver to buy bitcoin but i did so in a
moderate way and i am
a former professional wall streeter so i
do have some experience
i got one for you group b says tim is
this the guy that famously said have fun
staying poor that you
that you that you so much like to say
much wow okay
that is not me that is ooty we're timer
wartheimer he's probably i probably said
his name wrong
now that's gonna become a meme that's
the thing yeah yeah yeah
i i created a meme by um there's a
famous uh bitcoin meme artist named greg
zaj and i i thought it was like talking
about him on our live stream and i was
like
yeah there's this guy greja
their meme is like no it's greg and i
keep on saying it over and over it's
like no my name's greg
yeah yeah yeah all right we got uh amala
shock says tim here's ten dollars
earmarked for a limiter compressor
plug-in for your soundboard to keep your
your more dynamic guests from blowing up
ears uh how about this
what we need we need a professional
sound person uh
to come in and just get a set up we have
we have a new system coming in soon
and we need an av pro who can help us
uh set up the new system and it's gonna
be it's gonna be
going to have to be over a weekend
probably should be pretty easy to plug
everything back in
and uh yeah there you go so i have a
suggestion for a guest
yeah jack mullers who's that he runs in
strike and zap
which is a second layer bitcoin
application just came back from i think
it was ecuador
and it's now the the number one
financial el salvador the number one
finance app in that country and it's
he's changing lives he's changing the
world and he's a bitcoiner he's a young
guy i think he's a millennial
and um he could even be z he might be
he's just super dynamic and he built
this company from scratch
and it's it's as i said it's second
layer bitcoin it's like
we're having a conversation about
bitcoin but there's already
there's already something going on
that's well beyond it and that's
lightning so enlightening payments yes
jack mullers is
the the dude he's the guy and he would
be an excellent guest i really do
believe
i think sure too all right so uh samte
says china has bitcoin mining
superiority by a large margin
what does the future look like for
bitcoin mining all right that's not true
uh there first of all mining is
migrating out of china it's a lot of
it's coming to america particularly in
texas because it's all about cost of
energy and you get a lot of cheap energy
in china
in texas number two a lot of the mining
in
china is pools and that pools are from
all over the world so that's a mistake
that's kind of a misdomer that's a myth
so they're outsourcing computing power
yeah but it's gone in different
countries and it's
it's leaving china it's moving to texas
and texas is becoming a mining
powerhouse and it's
part of the beauty of bitcoin is what's
called game theory it's baked into the
protocol you've got these three major
elements to this game theory you get the
miners the nodes and the developers
and they're all working together but
also competing with each other
and as a result you have maximum
distribution or
decentralization and everyone is
incentivized to keep it decentralized
while
maintaining this protocol that emits
coins every 10 minutes
and uh offers this way out of the system
the number one thing about bitcoin that
i would emphasize is that it separates
state from money
we've never had that ever in the history
of the world all money has been
controlled in some degree by the church
or the state or some central authority
or a government this is the first time
we have actual
hard money that's completely separate
from the state and get individual
sovereignty so for all the people that
are
distressed about the riots and the
inflation
and the disunity going on with bitcoin
you have
individual sovereignty you have mobility
you have agility
and you have community and and that's
the most important thing about it
not price goes up or number goes up
that's not really the most important
thing about it
all right so charlie 27.99 says what's
the best way to buy crypto
right i use swan bitcoin can i do my ad
for swamp bitcoin yeah you shout them
out bitcoin go to swampbitcoin.com
forward slash orange pill
we get ten dollars free in bitcoin if
you register
oh and what you do is with this company
it's run by
bitcoin ogs and they are
dedicated to bitcoin maximalism and it's
very easy to set up a dollar cost
averaging as a matter of fact
i can create swanbitcoin.com forward
slash
timpool in a heartbeat and you know you
would get
um immediately it would be
something that would an easy way for
folks to get involved yeah we should do
it
let's do it people like send bitcoin to
the show or whatever um they would sign
up and
it's it's a business arrangement so that
oh yeah
you're your enterprise it's an affiliate
we'll get an affiliate link so this
affiliate link
would would benefit this enterprise okay
they're a excellent company bitcoin only
okay
um and uh it's set up as far as i know
it's already set up
it's already set up tim as far as i know
it's already up and running
the thing is happening in real time as i
understand it or if it's not
then why not corey i told you to get it
ready corey
if it's not up right now then you
freaking blew it corey
darn it corey darn it spooner says can
you talk about ripple being sued by the
sec
and the xrp ledger yes i can ripple is a
scam
it's a douche coin and uh but
the thing about it is that they
this is the problem with a lot of these
douche coins is that because they have
pre-sale and they
are out there uh with bags of cash they
can hire really great lawyers
so they've taken on the sec and the sec
is suing them for
legitimate reasons but they've got such
a cadre of very very high priced lawyers
that it's going into the courts it's
going into the battle
they they you know it's it's hard as we
said before the regulators are captured
so in my view if the scc
i i'm not convinced that these are not
simply looking to get a
to get a cut from from the guys right
from the
the ripple foundation or whatever i mean
it's so dodgy but
they were selling they were dumping like
billions of dollars a year
on onto um bag holders yeah so then yes
exit scam but
in in a way you know the the the bag
holders keep pressing that link in that
email
you know here download this pdf these
douche coins because they have pre-mined
coins and that's centralized they can
buy
they buy the twitter trolls so if you
mention
that on on twitter you'll get 10 000
trolls will show up those are all paid
trolls oh my gosh
who are working for a dollar a day to
just
that you see that with all the douche
the douche coins this is call them
powerpoint
but bitcoin has no central and
centralization there's no pr department
there's nobody behind it there's pushing
it it just it exists on its own merit
for the obvious reasons of bestowing
individual sovereignty in a time when
that is desperately needed
that's the important thing about it
number go up is great but having
individual sovereignty is
better than anything else particularly
in
circumstances that we're describing
today where our own sovereign nation is
crumbling before our very eyes
we need to start all over again the
millennials in the gen z
with bitcoin as their bitcoin standard
we'll be able to remake this country
take the best of the constitution the
best of the bill of rights the best of
the declaration of independence and
build and start from scratch
start from scratch build it up all over
again america is an idea it's not a
place it's an idea
you can do it you can help your
generation it's the savior
but gen z and millennials are split
pretty heavily and they need leadership
they don't that's where you come in
you're the leader you've got the beanie
the beanie it says it all it says it's a
thousand years there's no crowns it's
just beanies
make beanies great again hunky dory says
dollar
i think i know the answer to this but
this one's for you dollar used to have a
gold standard
what does bitcoin have what creates its
value how is all currency not notional
like the dollar right two answers to
that
first of all understand that what is
money that's a fundamental question
what is money what is money it's a
universal trade medium
how does it become money money becomes
money because people use it as
confidence
so thousands of years after using beads
and shells and different things
eventually gold became a universal money
became the most trusted money became
money because it's portable
it's divisible it's easy desirable no
you can't print it
no
and so it becomes money central banks
are big owners of gold and gold is a
tier one money it's a base layer money
so
um now what what makes fiat money not
good money because
it's it's easier to counterfeit it's not
backed by anything it's just paper
it's not base layer money as we said
it's backed by violence it doesn't have
any intrinsic doesn't have any value it
doesn't have any
uh backing to it um it's um
it's obviously it's it the key though is
that it's not scarce
right so fiat money can be printed right
that's the biggest problem and that's
the problem we're having today is that
even though it's backed by violence or
backed by the government you can print
it okay what about bitcoin bitcoin is
absolutely scarce so it's better than
gold in that respect because gold's
deflation is relatively scarce just
deflationary
it's more divisible it's more portable
and here's the thing about bitcoin which
you don't have with gold
as you point out you need a stamp gold
to make sure it's verifiable that that's
gold
with bitcoin the transaction is the
verification
it's self verifying you don't need a
third party you don't need to pay
somebody to verify that it's good it's
actually gold it's it's self
verification
it transmits value across time and space
right and then you get into the energy
okay it converts energy into the hardest
money that's to say the scarcest money
we've ever known as humans so it's
backed essentially by
energy so energy is converted into the
hard money
and then when you enter the hard money
universe you then enter what we call the
cosmic consciousness
or you're entering the global
unconscious which is what we do on the
orange pill podcast so we explore the
the the dimensions of bitcoin that we're
just now
understanding in terms of its promotion
of peace love and understanding
it's like the world with a soundtrack
from elvis costello
it's like love rules all it's the
beginning of the aquarius age
so yeah talk to me tim let me know
what's on your mind
the problem with this question i think
the easiest way to answer it for hunky
dory is he says
the dollar used to have the gold
standard what does bitcoin have
what did the gold standard have what you
misunderstand is that bitcoin is gold
exactly if you're asking what does the
dollar have well then maybe
we can we can you know what is what is
there's no what's what's what's cash
gold all value derives from human
consciousness confidence
consciousness no no it's confidence well
it's also it is confidence in that
people we know that money becomes money
if it's used people
use it as money and i'm willing to take
it i believe i can get something the
thing about it is that it can take
the value into the future the reason why
people don't use
chicken feathers or sand or hand puppets
or whatever is money is because it
degrades over time it has a lot of
entropy
which is the physical nation about it
gold has
very very little entropy of thousands of
years later you can pick the gold from
and so you know you would exchange gold
as money now because you know that in a
year from now it
someone will accept it in exchange for
something else whereas fiat money you
know that a year from now it'll lose
purchasing power and no fee no
fiat money in 300 years has avoided
trading at zero not even the british
pound has lost 99
and a half percent of his purchasing
power they all go to zero over 300 years
every single one has gone to zero tim is
that what you're going to put your
wealth
and your fortune into something like
that i will also point out gold actually
can be it can be used
gold is used that's not necessarily a
good idea because
to the extent that gold has utility
value and this is where like i have a
major disagreement with peter schiff
is that it actually detracts from its
uses money because what you want from
your money is pure price discovery based
on people making transactions
in terms of their valuation of what it's
worth for them at the moment if you
start to say that gold has use as
electronics you start to infuse that
conversation with it
to person the problem is inverted uh so
we need gold for certain things and
computers and and you know
back in the day with memory cards and
stuff like that and because gold was
used as a store of value
it became very difficult to get it made
things more expensive they needed to be
because there was a function for it
but i will tell you this you can't deny
that the core function of fiat currency
does exist and then when all is said and
done there's a real good use for the
paper money
what kind of nonsense is that toilet
paper oh right i knew that there was
a point here there's some use for it tim
showed us a secret bunker filled with
toilet tissue
yeah this place is amazing i i'm like
it's just a laboratory it's just a
warehouse of toilet paper it's a
labyrinth of
toilet paper you know i came up with a
really good idea for a
money spinner is like finding headphones
to go with
for women yeah like because like messes
with your hair
like i wanted to look like a female
clint eastwood
i got the poncho even though um
that's probably cultural appropriation
right
not with that color but i got it in
mexico city
and um the thing is but my hair gets
flattened right
like right how do you deal with that
i don't know wash it with cold water
before you get out of the shower
five bits or whenever you want to take a
coin yeah so
like you know how do you deal with the
volume at the top
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know what
else i like about the value of bitcoin i
want to get back to your hair
yeah yeah no i i want to get back to her
the the smart contracts the the
opportunity cost gained by removing
someone from the equation so right now
you send your dollar to the electric
company they have to hire someone to go
turn the knobs and turn the electricity
on for you
with bitcoin you send the bitcoin to the
electric company the smart contract
tells the computer program to activate
so you can remove that
actor from the the cause right that's
true yeah so so now instead you can
build smart contracts
this is this is it's really annoying
when you're trying to set up electricity
at your house you got to call the guy
and they gotta send somebody
out and then i gotta pay them they gotta
confirm the payment with bitcoin it's
like i sent the bitcoin thingy just
turns on instantly
this right it just intermediates this
doesn't mean layers and layers of
bureaucracy smart contracts i mean yeah
think about the results
contracts and electricity yeah
so right so how do you turn the is it
smart
turning electricity down is one example
when you get a new apartment
or a house yeah you got to call the
electric company yeah give them your
information
yeah then you got to send a payment and
then they keep changing their name too
imagine if instead you walk to your
house you have a new house
you walk inside and there's your meter
and it says
here's a barcode a scanner oh yeah send
a qr code it says send to this address
to turn on power
and you just scan it and then the lights
turn on instantly they call it trustless
because you don't have to trust that
someone's going to do the thing for you
yeah yeah and so as long as money
comes into this address power equals yes
it's that simple no
no more calling no more verification
just boom by the way you know bitcoin
world
bitcoin twitter is like watching this
right now oh cool
shout out i'm sure they're gonna have an
answer for my hair oh yeah yeah
all right we got uh colton lindsey says
since january i've been dumping
any fiat that i have into bitcoin and
leveraging it leveraging it
60 to 40 loan to volume ratio to pay my
bills each month
um i know this is ill-advised but
bitcoin is untouchable
love orange bill oh yeah i love orange
peel
go to youtube.com four slash orange pill
and subscribe
go watch us like it's it's it's next
level like
a lot of people have already taken the
red pill but yeah what happens next
after the red pill is the orange all
right here's we'll do a couple more here
we go cosmic love
pims the great says i have a 401k
through my company how can i reinvest it
okay so again bordering into financial
advice right
which i don't which i don't offer but i
will say that if you have a 401k or a
retirement account like this
it is possible to to get into bitcoin
with it
and a simple search on a search engine
will immediately take you to those ideas
huh okay but it is possible i'll say
that so you can
you can answer that question in two
minutes just answer 401k plus bitcoin
and you'll get a lot of good answers i
also have to say
f you greg craig oh yeah greg
yeah josh grazan well it's a yellow
pop there's some yellow cat pop guy
yellow pop
all right so here we'll take one more um
mchatton says google just deleted my
super chat saying if net goes down
bitcoin equals zero wrong it's already
carrying on satellites you don't need
the internet don't need electricity you
have nodes uh
wireless wireless nodes people are doing
wireless bitcoin transactions outside of
the to all
financial and i don't grid i don't think
the internet could ever go down at this
point
no of course like what happened
like remember he tried it he he turned
off the internet for like four or five
days
and then all the industrialists of egypt
but if you don't it
doesn't lose actually it's the only
place your wealth would still be
preserved within the bitcoin system
and as long as there's two computers
somewhere in the world they can the
mining adjustment adjusts down the mind
blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah
blah
blah
blah
blah
blah
blah
blah
blah blah blah it never goes away it
never goes away if you've ever been on a
cruise ship
the first thing about people tell you to
do is well before pandemic
is to download these apps yeah or if you
go to like burning man i think they do
this
where it's a bluetooth mesh network yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's a mesh now everybody's
phones are on and they're all talking to
each other yeah yeah
so these people trust that they do that
on a cruise ship i didn't know that yeah
so i went on a cruise
several years ago and they were like
download i can remember what the app was
called that's weird like what sort of
cruise
like it was it was a bunch of old people
no no the podcasting for which is
podcasters really yeah it was called a
bunch of super rich people i think it
was called summit at sea and it was like
10 grand to go on the cruise
yeah and like the disney people wanted
me to be there so i was like hanging out
with lady gaga's manager or something
but everybody had an app
and you could send a message i could
send i could send a message to
ian and my phone would send the message
through your phone
but you couldn't see it right and then
it would eventually that's what you can
do with bitcoin and they do in venezuela
right now and mesh that so here's what
happened here's what happened in egypt
when mubarak tried shutting down the
internet yeah
a group called telecomics hackers yeah
some of these people i remember this we
covered it
yeah so they started doing something
called operation white facts
where they spammed fax machines in egypt
with instructions on how to create dial
up internet
yeah and so what people would do is once
the unit was down take a phone line
plug it into their computer's you know
old school router what is these
and then oh call a certain phone number
and give them dial-up access internet
because you can't shut it down oh by the
way i brought plucky
who's plucky clutching is the world's
most famous economist
oh hello i'm plucky
[Music]
can we repeal the federal reserve act
sure
tim i'm talking to you cause every
question in the world i know i'm
plucking
the world's foremost economist
i don't know what to ask him fine tim i
come all the way here
i'm already gonna buy it oh come on i'm
starving to death and you don't have any
questions for me
what got to show your gut over here
what would be the first step to repeal
the federal reserve act plucky they
should just
start fire themselves bitcoin fixes it
sells bitcoin fixes it
all right i think we've heard it all
right everybody we're gonna have
we're gonna we're gonna get uh we're
gonna get more rowdy in the bonus i've
been coming over at timcast.com just
about an hour
i will figure it out so make sure you
subscribe to this channel smash the like
button
share the show with your friends you can
follow this show at facebook.com
timcast irl share the clips from the
show to help spread the word
and we're also on instagram at tim cast
irl what about your new affinity link
for swampbitcoin.com
there you go do i got to sign up for
that or something you're done it's done
all right great uh bitcoin promotecoin
is zipping to your account
promote your podcast promote your
podcast that's my article podcast
nice
youtube.com forward slash orange pill
max doesn't know we have a show
he just thinks we're sitting in the
living room okay and uh
and talking uh
so youtube.com forward slash orange pill
or join our telegram group
t dot m e forward slash orange pill and
you'll find
relentless optimism there's gone right
there no
no no pull points yeah you can follow me
and crosstalk.net
thanks for coming guys that was fun this
is fun and now
now we're doing an only only fans with
you yeah yeah that's right
max finally max has been waiting waiting
oh my gosh okay i'm really excited for
this bonus segment and i have to agree
with stacey that these headphones are
absolutely sexist they flatten your hair
there's nothing you can do about it it's
a pain in the neck you can follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter
we will see you all over at timcast.com
become a member and we'll see you all
there bye guys
you